现在已经是哎你找到了
然后现在那个就是已经是6月下旬了
不知道同学们有没有开始进入暑假
我反正是有点不太习惯
因为我以前印象中暑假总是在7月份开始
为什么6月中旬我们就进入暑假了呢
所以我要花点时间稍微试一下
但不管怎么样的话啊
我希望同学们有一个非常快乐的一个暑假
那首先的话呢
回答一下我们社区女同学们给我们提的问题
那其实在过去的一个多星期吧
我们在社区里面大概回答了还是蛮多问题
大概有200多个问题吧
各种各样的问题都有
不过呢我们现在发现一个小小的问题
就女同学悄悄的告诉我们说
那个有些问题
其实他们有些很简单很基本的问题
但是呢他们不知道这样的问题是不是合适问
或者说很怕自己问出来
显得自己好像我的水平是不是不够高啊
我非常能理解这种感受
因为我以前也是这样的
我特别怕那个有人问有没有问题
我又问哎
我问了一个问题
大家都看见
我都笑了
其实这是很正常的一个担心
但是呢我觉得就是
这其实就是我们要克服的东西
我反而觉得大家千万千万不要觉得
你的问题简单
每个问题都应该值得被回答的
只要有同学有问题
只要有同学问题不懂
那就是我们games104的责任
我们要跟大家讲明白了
跟大家去讲懂
所以呢有的时候
我们真的想听到大家那些真实的问题
因为很多时候如果我没有得到大家的问题的话
我们会误判
我们会以为这个问题其实很简单
这个就这个那个公式可能很简单
这个方法可能是大家都好很好
懂这个地方我是不是可以讲的简单一点
但是当我们收到了
同学们越来越多的问题的时候
我们就会意识到哦
然后那一趴同学们还没有基本的概念
我们需要给大家解释清楚
因为其实这门课程的跨度是蛮大的嘛
就是从比如说大家看看有一点点编程基础
甚至是没有基础
到已经有从业了好些年的我们的行业内的同学
但是我讲的话就是说呃
其实每一个我们的课程的同学
你的问题都应该被尊重
所以我特别鼓励大家把你的问题提出来
千万不要不好意思
因为我作为我来讲的话
至少我是很愿意那个回答这些问题的
而且这也是我们的一个责任
另外一个的话呢就大家也讲了
小引擎
大家阅读起来有很多困难对吧
然后呢我们现在确实在一公在做一篇那个文档
做一个文档
就是试图结结合大家的问题
把小引擎中的一些难点
一些困难点给大家整理出来
因为最近在准备课件呢是压力特别大啊
今天我们这一节课的课件
准备的是我们压力最大的一节课件吧
然后的话
所以的话呢实际上分给小引擎的时间不够多
这也是我们这个课程本身的挑战
因为104的课程
和其他课程有一点很大的不同
是说我们所有的东西都是现做的
就是说它不像其他的课程
老师们都有在大学里讲课的课件对吧
游戏引擎这个东西的话
首先他的资料非常的分散
而且很多的技术啊概念啊
在行业内大家都是有debate
就是都是有争论的
然后呢我们就会非常的小心谨慎
然后因为我们认为这是个中立的课程嘛
所以我们就会把各方面的资料都搜集搜集一下
然后基于我们对行业的理解
尽可能给出一个A记
这个相对中立
然后呢又相对客观的一个一个一个描述
如果实在我们搞不清楚
我们就承认我们不懂
我们搞不清楚跟大家讲问题在哪里
所以的话呢就这个课程准备会花很多的时间了
那我们后面会把更多的时间分给我们的小引擎
给大家更多的解释
我们在准备这个文档
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说其实同学们有很多问题
关于我们的小引擎呢
比如说我们最近收到最多的几个问题
比如同学问我们说
为什么你们要选用win这个API呢
这个好抽象
好难啊对吧
这个同学们在学习图形学的时候
一上来学的是什么
肯定是open吉尔
我学图形学
我学的就open吉尔对吧
这个这个什么set一个VIEWPORT对吧
set一个gr
You look at
一个最好最好用的叫GRUT
那个那个那个工具上来设置一个什么look at
就可以把所有东西全部搞完
那么为什么我们会选择win这么抽象
这么复杂的一个东西啊
这里面的话呢我们要跟同学们汇报一下
就是我们的想法
就是首先的话呢
就是就像我在那个图TOGRAPHICS
那节课里面讲到的
就是呃104的课程
特别想让同学们明白
就是啊我们的游戏引擎这个行业
它真正的未来的一个发展方向
那么这个毫无疑问的就是说现代graphics硬件
特别是有信心
我们会走向越越来越用户可以定制
可以自我去规划pipeline的这个时代
特别像computer sor这些东西起来之后
所以的话呢像van像DX12
它的设计理念相对于上一代的graphic a API
比如像DX11对吧
那个open gl的早期的版本
那是有有一个代际差的
所以呢我们就给大家直接打开了一个hard模式
就是说直接我们就看未来
因为同学们今天学的这些知识
你今天很难学不懂
没有关系
但是呢你至少你的foundation是正确的
然后你未来如果你真的想在这方面精进的时候
其实你的基础就相当于你上来就直接学
学习这个下一代的东西了
就没有在这个浪费在这个前面的东西
就像我们国家造航母一样
对不对
我们直接上来电磁弹射了
我们就不要搞蒸汽弹射了
对不对
因为那个技术积累的也没什么用处对吧
这个逻辑其实就是这样的
那么当然但是的话呢就是说呃选择
我可能还有一个点
就是说他是真正跨平台的
因为DX12和van其实是等价的
但是呢DX12它主要是面向windows平台
那我们很多同学有的人在Mac
有的人在LINUX上对吧
包括在移动端上面
所以的话呢wen在这一点上是有很大的优势的
那么接下来的话呢我们这所以在这节课程呢
我们给同学们提供了两个reference的这个网站
大家有什么关于motion的问题
在上面可以查到
具体的PICOLA的上面的问题的话呢
可以直接问我们的课程组
那么另外一个同学问我比较多的问题
就是说哎我们什么时候能用开源
这个这个就是说我们的matt passer对吧
就是我们的反射的这个这个处理器
那这个其实是也是最嗯应该就是难度比较大吧
就是其实这里面要用到一点点的这个LLVM呢
这些就是说这个这个这个C浪的
这些东西在里面
但这个东西的话呢
其实我们在后面首先要在课程配合课程
因为我们这节课要讲啊工具
工具的高级里面会给大家讲反射
摆设里面会跟大家讲一下它的一些基础原理
应该是在工具这节课讲完之后
我们差不多同学们开始把这个代码开源出来
但是具体的时间的话呢
也给我们课程有一点点点时间
就是我们要还要再做点准备
然后包括文档各方面尽可能配套的齐全一点
但是呢大家不用担心
这个地方我们一定会开源的
因为我们小引擎的精神就是开源嘛对吧
那么还有同学们就问我们说
就是说哎呀
我的这个小引擎的环境好难搭建起来
这个其实我们非常能理解
因为呃实际上我们是一个两难问题了
就是一开始比如说像我学编程的时候
那我就是用那个简单的VC打开了
我就可以直接建个工程对吧
那在那小引擎里面
其实对大家有一个很大的卡点
就是说你需要用一个SEMAKER去生成
你的整个一个project ution文件对吧
而且你都你如果是Mac
如果你是这个PC
它的方法都不一样
这个呢跟之前我们的遇到的调困难也是一样的
就是说如果你想提供一个
跨平台的解决方案的话
我们没有别的选择
SEMAKER就是一个最好的一个选项
但是这就是我们的一个门槛
所以其实呢呃我所以我的建议就是同学们
第一个包括我自己在聊
我其实因为小引擎最开始环境搭建不是我做的
是我们团队同学们一起做的
那然后我也是严格的按照read me1步步操作
然后呢其中有几个地方的修改
还是因为我操作遇到了卡点
然后我们大家一起来修改它
那么另外一个的话呢
就是啊同学们的话呢就是可以查一些资料
我们这边也给大家一点点的这个
environment setup的这个资料
那同学们其实如果以上步骤都用过了
还是有问题的话
就像我一上来讲那样
大家不要不好意思
直接就问我们就好了嘛
我们有那么多的微信群
大家就问我们
然后我们课程组的小伙伴们
还是会非常的积极给大家回答
所以的话
希望同学们能尽快的进入到
皮克拉这个小引擎里面去遨游
那么其实皮克勒引擎的话呢
它本身的feature呢我们目前来讲
经过这差不多有两三个月的发展机
特别是课程开始之后的一个多月
因为也收集到同学们的反馈
很多同学也在基于它开发
那我们基本的体系
其实已经构建的还算是比较完备了
包括那个playing editor整个一个编辑模式啊
包括我们有基于forward ring的整个技术架构
shadow啊
我们的那个就是动画系统
还有我们最近刚刚接入的我们的物理系统
有同学在问我们说
诶为什么你们要接joy这个小物理引擎
那我跟大家分享一点小小的背景故事啊
首先这个引擎呢我们是真的认真挑过的
因为我们要选择一个非常清亮的一个物理引擎
因为因为物理引擎的选项很多啊
比如像我们以前啊都用过的
像havoc physics x对吧
那包括就是还有其他的一些开源的物理引擎
那为什么选择joy
就是因为它很轻很小
就是如果大家有兴趣的话
你可以进去读的
如果我没记错的话
他只有几万行代码
另外一个的话就是这个引擎虽然小
但是诶人家是被大作用过的
就是然后像horizon地平线这样的作品都用过
它作为他的这个物理引擎
所以我觉得它本身算法呀
稳定性啊
鲁邦性能没有什么太大的问题
所以的话呢我们就把它接进来
这样
因为我们认为
就是如果大家想做一个小小的游戏引擎
没有物理的这一趴的话呢
感觉就会差很多
那么在最近的话呢
随着我们大家一起努力
我们把character啊
MOTO系统也都装了
装了进去
所以今天的小引擎呢
实际上呃基本上已经满完备了
它本身还能继续windows linux
Mac os
就像我们同学讲的是
我为什么要学104这门课
我觉得你学完104这门课
至少有一点就是你在做毕设的时候
你去pica这个引擎做出来的东西
我保证你可以秒杀你的这个那个室友对吧
那么所以的话呢
这就是呃我觉得一个非常有意思的
一个一个一个一个一个目标吧
就是我们的课程目标就是学完104
人均一个自研引擎
那今天的话呢就是先花10分钟
跟同学们回答一下我们前面的问题
那接下来开始我们今天的正主了
今天这节课讲什么呢
我们今天就讲一个这个游戏引擎里面
我认为是最默默无闻的奉献者
就是工具链对吧
因为在游戏里面我们看到的都是
比如说把每一个游戏引擎
它在宣传自己的时候
没做的时候
都说你看我有什么什么特别厉害的光照的效果
特别厉害的视觉效果
特别厉害的逼真的物理仿真
很少有人会讲说诶我的工具是有哪些进化
为什么呢
因为大家听不懂对吧
老百姓哪知道什么工具是什么
但是呢你在看他的第二天
基本上基本上是第一趴的时候
到第2part的时候
才会跟你跟专面向专业知识讲诶
同学们
我们最近工具又做了什么升级
但是呢一般像我们真正做引擎的人的话
第一趴我们看看也就过了
基本上5分钟就明白了
但是呢我们会真正花时间看的是
他在工具上做了什么变化
因为这才是引擎最核心的一个东西
好那整个引擎的工具链呢其实是非常大的
一个就是一个一个就是一个一个模块
那这个模块的话呢
我们其实大家知道
我们最近课程的日程做了调整
本来工具链我们只有一节课的
但是我们做完准备之后
发现工具链一节课根本讲不完
所以我们就把它毅力是真的多加了一个课程
当然了
有另外一个模块被我们挤掉了
一个课程我们就不点名了
好可怜
那个模块被我们挤掉了
那么我们工具链的话呢
就是我们今天第一趴先讲它的基础
就是说诶你怎么去构建一个最简单的工具链
怎么能解决他的资源加载
这个存储
包括就是怎么能够让这些工序之间不要打架
能形成一个链条
就数据可以可以传递
怎么样实现一个最简单的就是那个what you see is
What you get
就是说所见即所得的这样的编辑
包括工具链的这个plugin系统
这是一个工具链最基础的东西
那么到第二讲的时候呢
我们会讲一些相对比较高级的东西
第一就是说在一个实战型的游戏的这个这个
pipeline中
这些工具到底是怎么在一起协同工作的对吧
你到底需要哪些编辑器
每个编辑器的实际的要点是什么
那么第二呢
我们会跟大家讲一些工具链比较深的
比如像反射
大家很关心的
也是大家一直想问我们要的matt faster的源代码
如果你不懂这个反射的这一趴的话呢
那个源代码给大家
大家可能也很难看得懂对吧
包括在讲一些高级的概念
比如说像协同编辑
所以的话呢我们把整个工序分成两趴
第一趴基础
第二趴高级还是我们的传统节奏好
那我们就开始我们的这个就是
首先给大家讲一下
游戏引擎的工具链到底是什么
首先的话呢
其实这是一个我们自己画的一个游戏引擎
架构图吧
就是我们已经跟大家讲
就是说游戏引擎它本身的复杂度啊
真的像一个小型的操作系统
基本上现在一个游戏引擎都要达到
千万级代码的这个复杂度
那么在很多时候呢
我们看到的很多人都会把渲染
或者把一个这个这个rendering当成一个游戏引擎
但其实游戏引擎渲染只是其中很小的1part
那我们会说物理仿真是不是游戏引擎呢
物理仿真也是其中的一趴对吧
那好网络通讯这个状态模拟是不是这个物理引
游戏引擎呢也是其中的一盘好
你把这些东西全部合到一起了
你得到的东西是什么呢
是一个one time
就是它的一个我们叫做engine erra
但是在engine之上有大量的工具
其实我们在第一节课也讲到了
比如说各种各样的editor对吧
比如说大家最常见的就是场景编辑器
我在这儿可以构建一个我想要的世界
然后这里面的话我要编辑各种各样的游戏逻辑
像连电路板一样的
我们一般叫做graphic editor或者叫blue print一样
有些游戏里面叫blue print
游戏引擎叫blue print对吧
我们还有各种各样的这个材质编辑器
SHADER编辑器对吧
还有脚本编辑器
各种各样的东西
那这一系列常常的东西啊
它的复杂度或者说它的整个体量
一般来讲
如果对于一个成熟的商业引擎来讲的话
它的复杂度是会超过软弹的
也就是说我们觉得RUNTIME代码很难写
对不对
但是引擎的工具链的代码的话
它的总开发量
开发成本实际上是会高于引擎本身的
这个是一个就商业级引擎里面的一个general practice
那么这么一个庞大的庞杂的系统的话呢
实际上它的基础最坏的基础是什么呢
我们叫做DCC就是DCC
指的是就是说各种各样的
比如像3D max maya zbrush
就是PHOTOSHOP对吧
还有那个现在比较火的
像胡迪尼这些第三方的这些软件
它们生成大量的资产素材
这些数据都是易购的
它要经过我们的工具工具链
然后呢行进入到我们的整个的引擎的pipeline
那这个地方的话有一个词儿
就是那个大家以前讲过的
就是那个ACP对吧
就是那个就是acid conditioning piapi
那么工具链其实就在这个CP这一层好
那么工具链呢实际上它真正解决的问题是什么
这个也是我想让所有学过游戏引擎开发的同学
你将来拿去跟那些没有学过以前的同学去解释
你问为什么引擎要做工具
工具
核心解决问题是什么
那别人如果告诉你说哎他只是为了做编辑
生成游戏数据的那会
我你就可以嘲笑他
说
不好意思
你这个讲的还是业余的
我给你讲一个最专业的观点是什么
其实引擎工具它最核心解决的问题是什么呢
不是其实只是仅仅是为了造游戏
实际上是什么呢
它在调和几种不同思维方式的人在一起
协同工作的这么一个平台
为什么呢
其实我大家想象一下一个游戏团队
他真实的情况是什么
最最简单的有三类人
第一类人呢当然是我们思维方式特别严谨
动手能力非常强的程序员同学对吧
那么他们就是每天加了个眼镜
穿着格子衬衫的程序员同学
那一定是非常严谨
逻辑性很强
什么事情都要跟你讲逻辑
还有一类是什么
我们的artist artist
他不在乎你的这个算法是怎么回事
你的这个光照模型的底层数学物理
物理原理是什么
我要这个颜
这个这个山水更暖一点
我看见那个更冷一点
对吧哈
我然后我要这个场景
这个角色动起来的话更有质感一点
好吧
这些语言和我们程序的语言是完全不搭嘎的
所以他对这个世界的理解是非常感性的
非常非定量的
但是呢它又非常敏锐的
那么artist对这个就是游戏的这个
它的它的表达
实际上是一种用户体验向的一种表达
好接下来还有是理派人是什么呢
就是我们的设计师非常有创意
对不对
哎我希望那一拳打下去
能够能够打出一个非常爆炸的伤害
而且我每一下打击的时候
我一上来速度要慢
突然一下子加速
我要的就是这种打击感
我要的那种刀刀
这个什么刀刀入肉
拳拳入肉的那种感觉
那designer的想法又是不一样的
他很在乎就是游戏的打击反馈
很在乎游戏的这种数值的合理
那这三类人在一起的话
其实他所需要的这个就对于同样一个游戏
这三个人打开各自的工具的时候
看到的东西是完全不一样的
对程序员看见的是各种数据在跑这个场景里
有多少个静态
有多少个公仔舞对吧
而艺术家看见的是什么
诶
这个色彩我要调
我上次在上节课给大家讲的color grading对吧
还记得吗
就这个就是artist
非常符合artist的感觉
我要的是这种感
这张照片的这种这种年代感
完了程序员就疯掉了
但是artist明白他怎么去表达这个世界
那他需要有自己的工具
当然其实跟真正需要的更复杂
那么designer看见的是什么呢
一堆的这种这个这个策划数据
比如说我打击出去的P
我打出一个叫什么攻击体
就是在我的角色前面画一个形成一个方块
你的每个刀回过去的地方形成一堆方块
然后哪些是暴击区
哪些是轻机区对吧
然后哪一个地方我能把对方打出硬直
所以其实我们的工具实际上是让这几种
说完全不同语言的人在一起
能够共同演奏一首乐曲
所以我经常把我们的一个游戏团队
想象成是一个乐队
是一个交响乐队
然后呢游戏引擎的话呢就是调和啊
游戏引擎to chain
工具链
就是调和这种不同设定的人在一起工作的
这样的一个基础的foundation
就是呃基础的这样的一个基建的一个东西
所以这是我们理解就是说这个游戏引擎啊
two chain在整个游戏研发中的一个定位就是它
所以它在设计中的话
他要充分考虑到不同的使用者的这个思维习
惯和要点是不同的
这个需求不同好
所以的话呢其实以这个为例的话
大家看见这个引擎在就是这个工具链
这是我们选的real为案例吗
就是从一样输出的白魔的这样一个关卡
那你们看见artist
它会在各种各样的工具里面换来换去
它一会儿构建你的材质
一会儿做一个小的物体
然后迅速的去摆放
最终的话呢能形成自己这样的一个世界
这这其实这里面就看到
这大概将近30秒的这样编程里面
其实它已经involve了很多
很多的工具模块在里面
我在后面会详细详细讲到这里面
比如像particle有这个材质的那个party蓝图对吧
各种各样的东西在里面
这里面还更多的只是展示了artist
实际上策划那边的话还没有完全展开
那么工具如果我们想要做工具的话
那首先最难的一个东西是什么呢
是各种各样的GUIJI是什么
就是这个graphics user interface
就是说其实啊我们的无论设计师也好
还是美术也好
当我们面对这个这个游戏引擎的时候
面对我打开工具链的时候
我要输入大量的数字
我要调很多东西
稍等我喝点水
然后其实呢
你就会有大量的user interface的东西在里面
那这个在最早期的时候
大家知道我们啊
应该大家可能还不记得最早的这个月
人机交互界面是什么
全是文本对吧
在最早的叫有一个操作系统叫DOS系统
到那个DOS时代
然后逐渐变成了windows时代
而现代游戏引擎
我们的工具链
用到的GOI其实是非常非常复杂的
那么有各种各样的控件在这里面
这么丰富和复杂的UI的话
其实你要作为一个游戏引擎的工具链的时候
你首先要会驾驭这么多的GUI的东西
那这个事情简单吗
其实非常的复杂
那么这里面的话呢有两大类
大的这种实现的方式
第一种呢我们叫做immediate mode
就是直接模式
它其实非常简单
也很淳朴
就是说OK我想画一个这个编辑框
我想画一个下拉框
我想画个按钮
OK我就画吧
直接画上去
你决定画就画这样
每一帧的时候有游戏逻辑
直接告诉我的这个GOUEI系统
说我要画上我的控件
那这样的话呢就直接打到这个空间上去了
而这种模型呢其实是非常简单和好用的
它的好处就是直接直接简单
而且的话呢也非常的这个快
非常容易去剖了胎
但是它的坏处是什么呢
就是说扩展性是有限的
另外一个的话呢
就是说其实他会把很多的业务压力
压到了我们的逻辑这一点
那么其实在其实现在有些引擎呢
就是它的GI系统部分还在用
比如像unity的UGI对吧
包括像OMGUI系统
包括像我们的小引擎的GI系统
也是这样一个直接模型
它比较简单
但是因为它实现起来比较简单嘛
但是呢另外一种
当我们去做工具gr的模型的话呢
我们一般会用什么呢
叫RETURMODE
这个return mode的话
大家解释一下
就是最简单的一个理解
就是当我要决定画什么什么东西的时候
我并不是直接画到屏幕上去
我是先说诶
我要画画一个box
这个box是大小尺寸是什么
我把这些所有的信息全部交给一个一个一个
其实很像我们讲的graphics里面的command
buffer一样的
我把我所有的这些指令全存储在这儿
然后到了那个GUI的自己绘制的
那个逻辑的时候
他自己根据我已经存的这些指令自己去画了
这样的好处是什么呢
我相当于把这个游戏的这个逻辑和
和这个rendering好吧
把这个就是这个UEI的
这个不就经常讲的游戏会混了
其实工具它的这个GUI的话两个分开来了
那么这个模型的话呢
它的好处就是说扩展性非常的强
而且性能也很好
为什么
因为你的这些命令全部catch到一起
它不会是逻辑执行到一层
他就画一次
而是说全放在一起统一处理
另外一个的话呢
就是说如果你不去改变它
你就不用再去更新它的指令
这个其实呢也是非常符合我们的这个游戏
架构的理论模型
所以说其实目前大部分的游戏工具
用的GI模型的话呢
实际上是这个return mode
那么比如像unreal的这个这个UI啊
比如像最著名的WPF
就是windows的那个那个presentation foundation
就是windows的那个就是他做UI的那个框架
包括像大家特别喜欢的qt
我知道在大学里面同学们做很多课件
做很多实验的时候特别喜欢QQ
因为我也蛮喜欢qt的对吧
其实也是用这样的一个模型去做的
所以说这其实是我们在搭建机UEI系统
最主要的两个大的方式
那我们肯定会推荐大家用这个return mode
那么因为GUI是我在做工具的第一个房间
就是我首先性能画绘画空间
我不会画空间
那怎么给大家做工件呢
做工具呢对不对好
但是这个return mode实际上再往深处去讲的话呢
它有很多的叫设计的细节
这个细节是什么
叫我们叫design pattern
就是你的数据怎么去组织
你的绘制
怎么你的view怎么去组织
所以这里面同学们如果学过design pattern
女同学的话
一定会想到说诶这个地方我们是不是要讲一些
比如说MVVM啊
MVPMVC啊
啊对你猜对了
其实这个地方是非常重要的
就是在我们在讲design pattern的时候
就讲这个就是整个工具的UI系统的构建的时候
其实design pattern非常的重要
否则的话呢你很容易去写诶
一个两个工具
写一个两个功能
当时当你写到一个工具里面有上百个功能
然后十几十几个工具在一起的时候
如果你不去遵循或者遵守某一个design pattern的话
那至少以我的开发的经验来讲的话
基本上一定会炸的
这也是做游戏引擎很有趣的一件事
就是说它是一个非常考验我们的
就是工程架构能力的这样的一个软件开发
那么在这里面的话
最著名的几个pattern的话
比如说我们称为鼻祖的叫VC这个model对吧
这个是这个就是1978年提出来的
这个是真的很早真的很了不起的一个model
它其实最早要解决的问题其实非常的简单
就是说哎以前我在做UI的时候
我UI中有大量的代码去修改我的数据
数据中间有很多逻辑
那你这个UEI万一改错了怎么办
而且数据要改逻辑
你们的那个叫view要改你们逻辑你的数据
然后逻辑又要改UEI的呈现
它两个代码系统就全绕合在一起了
所以说在40多年前
大家就提出了MVC这个模型
这个模型其实我个人的理解啊
就是大家很多人对control理解每个人都不一样
但我个人的理解就是
我认为他其实把这个数据流清晰化了
也就是说你从model是单向的到view
然后view呢不能够再反过来写model
所以所以所以说你可以认为
就是model这个把数据输送给view了
但是model本身不会被弄脏
然后呢
你如果想修改这个model里面的logic的
这些数据的话
你只能通过control
它会进行各种处理
各种过滤
然后再去修改你的model这样的一个结构
这个环流的话因为变成单行线了嘛
所以很清晰
很容易切断
很容易管理这个就像我们城市里面交通的时候
如果都是双行线
然后全交错在一起的时候
你就很难管理交通
对不对
你们会发现诶
有些地方为什么实现了一个叫这个这个
单行线的管理
其实也是这个逻辑
那么其实这个MVC的话呢
实际上是一个最经典的
就是一个把这个就是view和model decoupling
开来的一个架构
这个架构的话呢实际上现直到现在吧
在web前端还有很多用处
而且的话呢大家也是就是对他做了很多的变种
很多的眼镜
真的它的变种是我目前知道是最多的一个
一个pattern了吧
那么在MVC之后呢
另外一个模型的话就是MVP模型
其实我比如说我在我在当时大学VC的时候
我的第一反应就是为什么我这个时候还要把view
还要去知道model呢
对不对
我view可不可以完全不知道model的存在诶
我后来等我学到MVP的时候
我就发现哦
原来我这个笑话别人老早就想到了
其实MVP我可以认为是一个更彻底的一个
把view和model decoupling的一个模型
就是说OK
你view完全就不知道数据的逻辑的存在了
那么这里面只管这个他自己的各种展示的空间
那么presenter呢他负责从model里取数据
然后呢呈现给view
也负责从view里面的这个用户交互反馈给model
这样的话他这个好处是什么呢
就是像我们这种超大型的软件工程
我有很多的功能模块嘛对吧
其实我们最大的一个需求是什么呢
就是unit test
就是说我要做单元测试
比如说我要测试你的逻辑
对不对
那你你的UI做还是没做
你做成什么样
其实跟我的这个model的正确性没有太大的关系了
大家想想对不对
比如说我的model里面一个叫学生成绩排名系统
我的model里面有学生
这个学校这个什么三好学生评判系统
那和你在view中怎么去展示三好学生的话
是不是没有什么关系
那这个MVP模型里面的话
就是说他把这个就分得很开
那这个的话呢
其实是一个我个人认为更干净的一个摘取
那么这个摘取的话呢
实际上它当然它带来的代价是什么呢
就是他把所有的复杂度扔到了presenter
this presenter变成什么了
就是他得既听得懂model的语言
又听得懂view的语言
你看就是他在这中间人是最辛苦的
他得懂两种完全不同的语言
这时候view也轻松了
model也轻松了
其实MVP模型写不好的话
其实presenter经常会写的非常的臃肿和肥大
但是呢
其实呢在目前的整个工具的实践中的话呢
我个人比较推荐呢是第三种模型是MVVM
就是说哎这个名字听上去
很多同学应该非常熟了
因为这个我如果没记错的话
最早是微软提出来的
那么你可以认为就是说
其实它跟MVCVP都有很深的关系
但是我个人认为它有一个很深的一个
有一个很重大的一个决定
是他非常了不起的一个决定
就是说他第一个像MVP模型一样的
就是他把view和model也是彻底分开了
他只是把中间那一层它不再叫这个
就是presenter了
它叫什么呢
叫view model
它它这个关系呢不再是用代码哎
写死了
就是说我在V那个presenter里面去
基于query view的这个API
E l corn model api
他用了一种机制叫做founding的机制
这个绑定机制就非常了不起
就是他观察到一个非常重要的一个事实
就是什么呢
实际上在我们去做各种各样的工具的时候
就跟刚才我讲工具的价值一个道理
就是说你是要把几种完全不同设定的人
放在一起工作
比如说我去设置一个工具的整个UI的时候
实际上它是什么呢
它是ux designer
交互设计师
他不会写代码的
他也不想写代码
他在乎的东西是什么呢
就是哎我这个按钮放在这是不是合适
我这样按钮按下去
他就下拉框还是个滑动轨
这样更合理一点
更好看
我应该用什么颜色一点什么呀
所以他希望一个完全独立的一个ecosystem
一个环境里面去定制自己的用户交互
因为他只对用户交互和体验负责
所以的话呢其实那个view的话
他不要再去写什么逻辑
也不需要知道别人的东西
他希望用最简单的
比如说用XML或者是那个ZA这个语言
我直接表现这种就是这种cascade的这种类
要的东西对吧
而且这里面的话呢我们尽量实现
要实现他们想要的所见即所得
然后view model的话呢是程序员写的
我要把这个数据绑定起来
但其实只是定义了一种简单的绑定关系
那么真正复杂的model
那我自己去写我自己的数据
那么实际上这里面有一个非常大的好处
就是说那个model和view
真的是彻底彻底的分离开来了
那么这样的一个系统的话呢
它非常的干净
但是这就要求你如果想实现MVV的模型的话呢
你必须要在已经现成的框架里面
比如像WPF
他就给你提供了很好的框架
就是很多设计师你用那个就是啊ZARA这个脚本
或者用他的编辑器
就可以自动生成各种各样的UEI
然后呢你写一些非常简单的c#的代码
你就可以把这UEI全部就可以做出来
所以说以前我们在用C语言
C加加语言写UEI的时候很痛苦
而且很难debug
经常是UEI就崩掉了
但是今天大家用c#的话
你会发现哇非常的灵活
非常的方便
而且别人写好的空间
我也很容易的思路都用起来
这其实就是MVI模型这个很大的一个好处
灵活性
当然了
这个模型的话呢
其实他也有自己的一个困难
就是第一个
我认为它是需要在他自己的那个生态里面
就比如说你要去做这个这个MV模型
在windows的情况下
你最好的选择
目前我看到的还是WPF对吧
但是你这样做完之后
就以前像那个mono啊
像这些东西做的不够好
比如现在那个DNA的那个框架
在LINUX上支持的不是特别好的时候
那我想把它清迁移到LINUX呢
我想把它迁移到Mac上怎么办
那就很很很痛苦
所以说这个时候你实际上是
你对这个环境的要求就比较高
第二个的话呢就是对于一些比较简单的
极其简单的UI需求的话呢
这个框架呢它本身的就是这个可维护性
或者叫DEBUGABILITY
本身也有一点点挑战
因为其实大家特别容易在哪个地方
在邦尼那个地方出错
因为这两个无论是view你去定义它对吧
view model你去定义它
它两个呢你只是做了一些declaration
当然这个逻辑到底是不是真的是对的
这个逻辑之间的关联是不是真的是有效的
你不把整个系统跑起来的话
你是没有办法验证的
如果这里面的数据出问题的话
就debug起来是比较痛苦的
但是呢这毫不妨碍
就是MVVM的话是一个在商业上已经被证明了
非常成功的一个模型
当然这个模型其实现在也还在不断的演进
因为啊确实我们现代软件系统越来越复杂
所以说其实我们再去思考
就现代软件系统的时候
就是比如说做到to train这一块的话
我们一般跟大家去讲
就是说尽量不要自己去造轮子
因为我们的关注点首先是游戏引擎
游戏里的东西
所以我们在做two chain的时候
在我们写我们to change的GI这个体系的时候
首先to change的GI体系
刚才再强调一下
非常的重要
而且呢它需要需要有非常强的工程可扩展性
你才能够支撑你全部的需求
那我们的建议就是说大家不要自己造轮子
选择最成熟的结构和方案
比如说我有有些小引擎
你如果真的急了
你想用qt去写
其实我认为也是可以的
但这一定比你自己去写一个要靠谱的多
对吧好
所以的话呢就是说讲到这儿
大家首先明白
就是GI大概以什么框架去构建呢
那么如果你在windows下的话
如果你不考虑跨平台
那WPF肯定是个比较好的一个选项
那那你就follow mv m的这个模型
这样的话你能够快速的构建各种各样
你想要的工具
你有了这样的一个东西的话
接下来你要面对的问题是什么呢
就是数据对吧
我们有在这个工具链里面
传递的就是大量的数据
那数据第一个需求是什么呢
就是哎load and save
就是我加载或者是存储
因为数据我不太老师在内存中放的对吧
那么这个事情呢
其实等等我们真正设计这个工具链的时候
它并不是一个很trivial的问题
就并不是一个非常简单的问题
那么首先跟大家讲一个学术名词啊
这个名词其实非常高大上
这个叫serialization and deserialization
序列化与反序列化
听上去好像非常的高大上
其实就是啊这个save and load就反过来
serialization就是存出去
把它变成一个可以传递的一个二进制的块儿
this alization就是把一个二进制块
把它变成一个我能够内存中可以解
可以处理的这样的一个数据
那么但是呢就是这里面大家特别容易犯的一个
一个误解什么的
就是SATION和DISORATION并不只是单纯的指的是文件
实际上这两个概念是很广泛的
比如说SATISATION
它不只是存成我的磁盘上的文件
我还可以存成我的数据库里面的一个block data
就是说因为我很多数据
比如说我一个对象的描述对吧
我一个object的GO
大家记得我们游戏讲一切都是GO
其实我的CEO的状态
可以把它serialize成一个二进制的数据块
我可以把它存到数据库中
我用object id去引用它
这样的话我随时随地可以去访问它
还有呢就是我还可以把它存到网络上去
就是说啊这不叫疼
叫传输了
就是说我的客户端A向客户端二
或者向服务器发送一个消息的时候
实际上我要把我的一个机油的那个所有的描述
也要把它serialization乘一个二进制的数据流
然后通过网络协议传到另外一个客户端
另外客户端拿到这个二进制的数据流怎么办呢
他要对他进行DISCIALIZATION
然后呢把那个机油再构建出来
其实我们的整个游戏特别是网络
我们后面还有一张会跟同学们讲
那个就是networking
就是说怎么去做可以互联的游戏的话
会跟大家详细的讲
这里面有很多有意思的东西
但是selection disciation的话
也是networking的一个很重要的一个foundation
所以这两个概念的话呢是啊
可以讲是现代游戏
现代系统
特别是现代游戏引擎吧
我们认为是个非常foundation的概念
因为在工具链
在游戏引擎里面
就是我们每天面对的就是数据的
你把它打打包好
解包打包好解包
就是我们每天日常干的活儿好
那其实呢这个打包的方法
最简单的方法是什么呢
是text文件
哎大家不要笑啊
text文件虽然非常简单啊
但是其实实际上在最早期的时候啊
比如说我们讲那个网络之间的通讯
大家想象一下是怎么做的
诶我们可以用text铭文做的
大家还听我相信同学们看见很多
这就是互联网的八卦
就是某某某这个很牛逼的
这个什么这个这个某某国的重点什么系统
结果呢
它的这个重要的信息都是用text铭文存的对吧
所以你看这件事情
是不是让大家都觉得笑掉大牙
但实际上这是个很常见的一个事情
就是说其实TT它有很多好处
第一个呢就是说它本身是非常容易
就是理解被人去赌的
第二个的话呢
你用任何一个工具就能打开它
这样的话你去debug
你去追踪
你去分析特别的容易
那么实际上的话呢TT在最早比如说啊
同学们如果学那个就是学图形学的话
最早应该接触过一种格式叫点OBG格式
这个是个非常古老的格式
那这个格式里面它就是真的很淳朴
说哎V打头机表示我是个vertex啊
接下来三个三个text是告诉我的顶点坐标
然后呢我好像记得是T打头还是什么打头
就表示三角形还是M打头
我有点忘了
就是呃应该是T打头还是什么打头
它表示一个三角形
然后就表示三角形对吧
index123456789十
那么其实这些呢最古老的text format
真的就是每个程序员自己想到一出
是一出就定了的
但是呢等到后来大家就会发现啊
我们这样胡乱定是有问题的
后来就出现了一些
更多的一些就是我们叫结构化描述语言
比如说XML对吧
XML包括像HTML这些语言
其实XML是个非常了不起的一个发明
就是说他意识到了就这些文本
它实际上是个容器
然后呢它通过一个树状的一个标注系统
能够把任何一种结构化的信息都放进去
那么这个东西的话呢其实是很多系统的一个foundation
那当然后来大家就发现就是哎呀
XML这个废话特别多对吧
每个描述都一大堆
那个标号啊
间号一大堆
后来有人就提出了更轻量的一些方法
比如说像JASONJASON就是它的功能跟XML非常接近
但是呢JASON他的这个语法
就是它的这个文件大小就会小很多
另外一个呢它的passer就是它的处理也会快很多
那么像包括像那个压秒这些语言
所以其实啊就是text file
如果大家在做引擎
做工具链的时候
如果你做的体量不是特别复杂的时候
我倒是非常推荐大家先用text file去上手
因为你一开始写的时候会有很多的bug
这也是同学们问我的问题
就是为什么这个PICO我们选择了JASON这个语言
其实就是为了方便大家阅读和理解
比如说我如果用二进制的格式的话
同学们根本不知道那个数据里藏了什么东西
而且它的数据的读取也非常的抽象
然后最后进了引擎之后
数据正确了不得了
谢天谢地
数据错误了呢
你就觉得哎呀完蛋了
我我都不知道
无从下手
因为大家如果debug过
对那个二进制的数据的解析的时候
你就知道那个事情真的是非常的痛苦
所以的话呢我们当时就选择了
就是说用JASON作为我们这个数据的语言
那当然其实类似的选择
比如像unity
它也提供了一种就是A纯文本的方式
去存储你的S的
包括像那个就是那个corue engine的话
它也有一个就是类似于用那个CHARML或者
JASON的这样存储模型
其实我如果大家在写这个引擎的时候呢
我会推荐大家就是首先支持text f
这样的话
就相当于给你的引擎加入了一个debug mode
就是哎你任何一个数据错了
你先把数据转成那个textbook md
然后debug1遍
如果没有问题
你才转成八点后买的
这个其实是一个非常好的一个option
那么第二种呢也是大家很自然会想到的对吧
我这么这个这么蠢的
存了那么多的
这个这个这个这个这个文字肯定是最慢的嘛
那我直接用BUE去存
那这个其实呢就是它的存储容量
肯定是很有优势的
比如像unity他一上来啊
Unreal
它的所有的模型里面基本上都是binary的
比如CRYIN也有binary mode对吧
所以的话呢
这个呢其实我认为是很自然的一个东西
就是如果你有了一个基于text的一个结构的表达
你把它转成二进制的话
实际上也是非常自然的一个表达
那么这两个的好处呢
我相信不用我讲
同学们也能猜到
就是二进制会小很多
举这样一个模型的例子的话
同样是用FBX就FX的话呢是行业
你现在特别特别通用的一种
这个数据模型的表达格式
对不对
他就很聪明
它提供了两种format
一种for binary
一种for text对吧
这就是for deparability
那么你会发现就是text的这个文件
基本上接近于这个binary的十倍以上对
而且呢大家都知道就是我读二进制的时候啊
我几乎不要进行语语法处理
但是我要读文本的时候
实际上我要做语法passing什么意思呢
就是说我得把你的逗号句号尖角号
然后要做包括你的注释
我都要做语法的语义的过滤对吧
我要生成一个ST
然后呢基因的语义我再把你keyword build dictionary
我要做很多很多的处理
其实那个text的加载速度
应该确实比巴黎人慢的就将近十倍不止
所以呢这个就是一个debug很好的mod
但是呢确实比如说像我们的真正的
你要做一个上线的游戏的时候
那你的资产包括你的整个asset的格式
一定是要换成BINNER的
还有一个点是什么
你不想被别人破解
所以的话呢其实我们如果再讲一下的话
那asset其实有的时候我们需要加密的加密
那就是另外一套很神奇的算法了
今天就不展开了
那么其实呢在这个资产里面
我们会发现很有意思的一件事情
就是说其实我们打开一个游戏的关卡
你会发现你们很多资产是重复的
那么那怎么办
那我们最自然的想法是什么呢
诶我们其实把有些资产
比如说一栋房子变成另外一个资产对吧
比如说我要表达一个场景的时候
我这个场景里面有1000栋房子
但是一千一千栋房子可以用20种房子去表达
所以呢这个时候
其实在我们定义我们的数据结构的时候
我们要引出一种很重要的东西
叫做asset reference
就资产的引用
这个其实当我们在定义一种
就无论你是二进制的还是text format的
这样的一个S系统的时候
你一定要支持就是cross five的这种引用
因为你有了这样的引用之后
你才能把这些重复的东西全部给提取出来
这也是当我们去做一个引擎工具链的时候
实际上你面对的不是一块巨大的数据
你面对的是什么呢
是成千上万的离散的文件
而且这些文件之间呢它们彼此之间是关联的
比如说你做个特效对啊
你觉得特效就是我自己的
对不对
诶不好意思
你做个特效
你首先可能引用到一个诶特效的蓝图对吧
如果是real的话
你可能会用到什么呢
你自己的本身的这个texture
我需要用到这个动动画的texture
我可能要用到那个的animation
所以它的过程其实蛮复杂的
这就是游戏引擎
就是游戏引擎reference
为什么重要
就是你可以认为游戏里面是上上万上10万
上百万的这些资产文件
他们是像一个出网一样的
彼此关联在一起
所以的话呢这也是reference的引用驱虫
实际上是我们的资产系统
最核心的一个底层逻辑
也是工具链的最核心的底层逻辑
好
那么你有了这样一个reference的话
有一个最简单的做法就是诶
我在一个尖顶的房子
在我的场景里出现了十次
我只需要放它十次的引用
那么这个十次都是这个房子什么的
我们叫做instance
就是它的一个实例
而你那个房子本身的定义本身叫什么呢
它是它的definition对吧
这个我在之前好像在instant deapi里
反复跟大家讲这个概念
但是呢当我们在做工具链
特别是因为工具链
会直接影响到你底层的数据结构嘛
那其实你会遇到一个真实的情况
就是在做实战程序游戏的时候
其实很多时候artist诶
这个时候就反映出artist课
程序员思维方式不同了
比如说这个artist把一个房子
比如一块地板
我考了十遍之后
那作为程序员的想法就是
哎你我都已经让你能考十遍了对吧
而且我还只用了一份的存储空间
我已经很厉害了
对不对
但是说不好意思
我觉得考了十遍
虽然它分散在各个地方
你提供了让它旋转放缩各种变化
但是我觉得还是不过瘾
我想把其中五个的贴图给换了
换成其他的贴图
这个程序员就很抓透了
他就说啊
那你只要换了他的这个比如说它的贴图
那就你应该做一种新的定义呀
但是呢诶不好意思
就是作为我们的艺术家
他不会这样去做
因为他在那个编辑环境里面
他希望所见即所得
就是我看见这个贴图不爽
我马上就要把这个图换掉
那这个时候呢
其实我们在工具链中对每一个对象
对对它进行实例化的时候
我们要给他做各种各样的
就提供一种叫做warrens的能力
就是做它的变种的能力
那这个时候呢实际上就会要求我们啊稍等
其实呢就会要求我们说诶
我能够直接在工具链中
把一个物体做出它的变化
那最简单粗暴的做法是什么
诶
我把这个物体在我的这个关卡里面
再拷贝一份对吧
然后你想改啥就改
大哥你牛你你你考完之后
随便你怎么改
但这个做法的话
显然从数据处理上呢
它是一个低效的做法
为什么呢
因为你可能一个物体的描述
我有成千上万的数据对吧
可能是比如说几百个数据
你只动了一个
比如说它的颜色
它的一张贴图的纹理的这个路径
那其实你改的东西很少
还有一点
就是说
比如说我向总体上对的东西进行一个调整
比如说我把他的一个网格做了调整
我希望其他的他的分身都要相应的发生变化
但是一旦你拷贝之后呢
他们之间的关联就彻底断掉了
所以呢这个时候我们引入了一个很重要的概念
叫什么呢
叫做DINHERITANCE
这个的话呢
实际上也是工具链一个非常重要的
一个底层技术
就是说我们当用户在这么多工具中
来回走的时候
它会产生很多数据嘛
其实数据是可以继承的
对数据是可以继承
大家在学这个就是啊高级语言的时候
大家在学C加加对吧
我们定义了一个类
我们的类的派生
它就是继承于它的父类
对不对
好像就是我的方法
我的很容易可以继承
那么数据可以继承什么意思
就是诶我一个111个structure的一个实例
比如说我把它的长宽高的设了个数值
我另外一个数据呢是既乘以你刚才那个
比如说长高一个一个正方体的box
但是呢我长宽都不改
我只改你的高
诶
我这个数据就是给你继承的
而数据继承的话呢
也是我们在做这个引擎工具链的时候
一个非常重要的一个方法
这个方法其实你说它难吧也不难
也就是说
实际上就在于我们的定义这个数据资产的时候
定义asset格式的时候
大家刚才讲的
比如像我们这个用的是类似于CHARA的格式
那实际上你加入一些相应的属性段
描述说
哎我这个数据它其实是继承于哪一个那个数据
然后呢但是我哪个field我要改掉了
我就把它改掉
那这样的话
当我们工具链或者我们的引擎
读到这一块数据的时候
我就知道先把原始数据朝拷过来
然后呢根据你的修改的部分把它修改掉
这样我就造出了一个新的数据
所以其实非常的有意思啊
这个实际上在你去大家去理解工具链的时候
实际上工具链玩的全是数据
就是它实际上是各种各样的数据
在各个工具之间流来流去
那么怎么去深刻地理解数据
怎么样的保证数据的这个灵活多样性
但又不会混乱
实际上是我们在做to chain的时候
一个非常核心的一个一个发力点
这个概念还蛮好玩的
那我们把这些数据我们知道怎么去存在的对吧
我们把这个数据存到硬盘上
就是那个其实刚才我讲了那么多
我只是把serialization part给讲好了
怎么样
我的标题叫low and save
但其实讲了半天
我只讲了如何定义数据
如何save数据
那真正难的问题就来了
这个磁盘上的数据我怎么去漏的
他呢就是我怎么去DCALIZATION呢
唉这事儿其实并不简单
这个呢如果你不去做引擎的同学
大家不用太关心对吧
反正format的人家一定好
我直接用就好了
但是如果我们games104的小伙伴
大家想做自己的引擎
想定义自己的工具链的话
那这一盘的话同学们要去听一听了
诶实际上这个事情其实是我们对一个asset
加载进来之后
我们并不是像大家想象的
我沿着文件一通读就完事儿了
实际上它是一个passing的过程
什么叫passing课程
大家想象一下我们一个场景文文件
它里面有很多的数据块
每个数据块有很多field
有些field的话呢它有不同的value
不同的type对吧
那你怎么去处理它
实际上呢你是要对整个文件进行
不不是说依次去读它
你要对整个文件进行扫描
然后呢扫描的时候的话呢
你要去去检查每一个field是不是存在
比如说你检测到一个一个key value
它的名字叫什么好
你接下来说诶我找到你的值了好
我把你的名字值type
我就把你放到一块
变成一个pal
但是有的时候我我说诶
你你指向了你们另外一块数据
但那块数据呢其实我还没有没有读到
大家想象一下
我我们看一个数据的时候是一个完整的
就是整合在一起看
但是其电脑大家讲记得我以前讲过图灵机
对不对
图灵机是什么
是一个纸袋
他这样只能一次一次去打
但是呢它有一个小小的memory
这个纸袋一直打写memory memory是另外一条纸带了
那我看到一个是一个数据库
比如说你现在要用到这个你这个呃
比如说吧你这个动画啊
不说错了
比如说你这个角色
他的第三个动作是要用到动画305好
305动画还没读
那我再继续往后读读读读
读到后面的时候诶
我动画305的那个动画我才能读过来
读过来之后我才知道这个数据是什么
所以说其实这里面的话呢
我并不是一上来把所有的数据全部加载进来
而我一上来是先要把这个数据拆分成
一个个的语义
然后呢把这些所有的关键的key
这些value
这些type全放在一起
它会生成一个什么样的东西呢
哎大家看我们最后生成一个所有的field的这个key
然后呢它是什么类型
还有它的这个值形成一个树状结构
大家如果去分析一下所有所有的像XML
像JASON这样的语言的话
你会发现它无论多复杂的这个文件
这个asset它都是个树状结构
其实在我们在做游戏引擎的这个资产
asset的管理的时候
我们也是用了这种结构
就用树状结构
其实这个很像什么呢
很像那个就是那个大学那个编译器的时候
那个a s d tree对吧
就是你写了一段很长的这个
文本的这个源代码诶
其实交给编译器的时候
他管你写的这个这个这个妙笔生花
给你生成了一群非常抽象的s d tr
AST长什么样呢
大家稍安勿躁
我们在下一节课给大家讲反射的时候
会让大家见识一下
那个这个这个这个很就是让你觉得大跌眼镜的
STT长什么样的这个结构
但今天我们展开
但是呢它的逻辑上其实也是像这样的一个结构
其实这就是我们对世界的表达
就像我们去理解这个宇宙
理解这个世界
其实如果我把对象一个个都罗列的时候
我们是没有办法理解这个宇宙的对吧
那我们怎么去理解这个国家很简单
我记得我在上节课的
在前几好几节课讲过这个概念
就是诶我们构建一个树状结构
我们首先第一个题
第一个根节点叫什么叫国家好
我们把国家怎么分呢
诶我把国家分成审审
分成市是在分成这个就是每一个区诶
这另外一个呢我在这个市里面
每个区里面我在分人
但每个人怎么样
然后这个国家另外的一趴
比如另外一个业绩点是什么
我是按企业啊
行业按部门按部队这样一个个分诶
我用一个树状结构
就可以把一个极其庞大复杂的系统给表达出来
而且这里面的话呢
他们彼此之间还可以相互引用对吧
比如说有一个个体的人
他属于哪个神啊
哪个市哪个省
哪个市的一个人
但是呢他又属于哪一个政府部门对吧
他又是从事什么职业
然后他和谁谁谁又有什么配偶关系
所以其实啊这样的一个树状结构
它就彼此之间能够相互引用
实际上就是我们的一个asset的一个
真正底层的结构
那么这个时候如果我们去加载一个
就是text format的话呢
实际上前面需要一个非常复杂的一个passing课程
比如说大家去理解一下
就看我们的小引擎
我们不是用JASONJASON作为我们的数据载体吗
你可以你如果读那段代码
你会发现我们首先调用的是那个第三方的库
它把JSON的文件就变成了这样
一个一个一个tree的structure
然后呢他们也它也可以叫做dictionary一个字典
然后呢我要任何数据我就问他
然后我就可以通过他的第二次处理
我可以拿到我想要的我的资产
但如果你是二进制的话呢
其实一般在二进制的头部
我们会把这个树状描述存下来
就比如说我有多少个field
它的名字叫什么
他的type
它的它的位移在哪里
就是数据在那里
第二个就是他到底什么态度
因为我知道tab就知道我要读多久
我先把整个这个二进制文件的描述放在前头
那接下来的数据我就可以快速的去处理了
所以的话呢
这个其实当我们去做DESERIALIZATION的时候
这是一个非常重要的一个方法
OK好
那么但但是呢如果我们用二进制做distortion
特别是我们在做真正的工具链的时候啊
大家要特别特别注意一个事情
就是ending这个词是不是大家觉得很很神奇
这个ending中文叫什么呢
说句实话
我也不知道中文叫什么
反正而且这个东西在我个人看来是我
我我是满满满觉得这个头疼的一个事儿
就是说呃大家知不知道
就是在我们计算机这个系统的早期的话
有两派之争
一个叫big ending
叫leader
你这个很像甜豆浆和咸豆浆之争
真的是特别特别无聊
但是给我们惹了很大的麻烦
就是说同样一个比如说一个整数
你是把第一位存在前面
比如说把个十百千万第一位存在
但是二进制里面是倒不是个十百千万对吧
就是低位我存在前面
还是把高位存在前面诶
这两派就打起来了
那么比如像INTEL的X86架构
它就是一个little ending对吧
但是呢比如说像IBM的power pc架构诶
它就来了个big ending
你说这有意思没意思对吧
但是呢没办法
这就是事实
比如说我们要兼容LINUX不同的这个硬件平台
我们要兼容这个Mac
还兼容那个就是说各种android的
还有还有就是那个游戏主机
还有那个就是PC
哎我们就得要解决这个很奇怪的问题
但这个问题呢你说它复杂吗
也不复杂
我跟大家讲一下
就是说在当我们做游戏引擎工具链的时候
我们实际上呢是这么解决这个问题的
就是说在工具链里面
我们一般会约定好我整工具链
比如说我们一般是去PC作为它的这个编辑器嘛
那我全部统一锁死为lut ending对吧
然后呢无论各种编辑器里面我就用
但是呢当我在做DISCIALIZATION的时候
也就是说当我加载这些数据的时候
比如说我突然发现诶
我好像是在一个PLAYSTATION上面去解压缩我的数据
对不对
我用一个swapping
就是把所有的little ending的数据
把它变成一个beginning的数据
但这个过程其实可以离线做
就是说当我去给PS5打包的时候
我把这事给做好
这也是可以的
但是呢就是当我们去写引擎to chain的时候
这个确实要注意
包括我们现在都已经遇到这个问题了
所以的话呢就是同学们如果做引擎的时候
诶
知道跨平台里面
这个ending就是一个很头疼的一个小问题
好那么讲到这儿
大家就会觉得哎呀
我基本上虽然我好像听得半懂不懂
我好像已经知道这个工具链基于此
基于S系统怎么去构建了对吧
我既知道GUI怎么做了
我也知道这些数据怎么去组织了
接下来我接下来的问问老师
怎么去构建这些编辑
我基本上就能做
对不对
哎我现在跟大家讲一个更有意思
也是
其实我一直认为是做工具链最难的一个问题
就是说你怎么能做到
就是说资产的这个版本的兼容性
哎这个大家就很难理解了
为什么还有一个版本兼容呢
比如说同学们
你们在用word的时候对吧
有多少人意识到其实word是个非常难写的软件
比如说我是2010版的word对吧
然后呢我编辑了一个文档
诶
这个时候我假设是一个2019版
2020版的这个word
现在应该是2023了吧
版本的这个这个word出来
我还要能打开
2015版本的那个那个word文件诶
这个向下兼容大家想想怎么写
而且大家想要哦
这很简单嘛
我就check一下版本号
衣服你的版本对应20142010
我怎么怎么样对吧
那当然你这个做法也是可以的
但是我们在想更偏激的做法
就是假设你这个资产是啊二
这个这个文件是2023
编辑完了
那你二零这个一零的版本能不能打开
那现在反正沃特的处理是很糟糕的
实话实说
他基本上是没办法打开的
他说哎呀
你这个好像是版本号更高
我打开不了对吧
但实际上的话呢
其实在我们在做游戏引擎工具的时候
我们要支持版本的兼容性
就是这原因是什么呢
首先大家想象一下
一个游戏真实的研发过程有多久
大概是3年左右
那么在一年在3年前
大家做了很多资产
比如说我编辑了一个很漂亮的动画对吧
我做了一个很酷的场景
那我引擎会不停的升级
我的工具也在不停的升级
我会加很多很多的数据
我可以删掉一些数据诶
那难道我们的美术3年前做的那个场景
就不能打开吗
那你想想看美术是不是要跟你拼命
对不对
人家工作了几个月的成果
你以为你老人家版本升级
大家就就就完蛋了对吧
那么还有一点是什么呢
就是说诶就是我这是就是过去的数据向
就是叫我们叫这个叫做backward compatibility
就是向后兼容对吧
那我们在讲for compatibility什么意思呢
就是说诶在我们一个团队里面啊
其实大家很多时候
版本工具基本上每隔一两天就升级
但有的时候同学们呢它的工具还是老的工具
但是呢他要打开未来的人类
就未来的同学们的版本创造的这个这个素材
这个情况其实是有的
那我们也希望这个工具不要崩掉
这个引擎还继续能跑
其实这个需求呢大家会觉得诶
好像如果我做好这个团队的管理对吧
我用老的平台跑未来的数据
这个事情应该不需要
但事实上呢在很多环境中
特别是在我们叫做分布式部署的环境里面啊
这个需求是很刚需的
这个特别像同学们特别想知道的什么
元宇宙对吧
我个人一直认为元宇宙这个概念现在很不成熟
因为就是呃他就有大量的这个问题
就是说比如说我几年前开发的一个应用
我未来来的数据
比如说我来自于啊未来这个别人生产的那个application
产生了一个虚拟人
他怎么进入到我3年前开发的一个
就比如说一个虚拟游戏场的这个环境
诶
他在我这也能玩
我不能因为这个他的那个application
我再去升级我的游戏
常因为很可能做了老的application
那个团队他已经他已经解散掉了对吧
其实在METAVERSE上会有很多这样的application
它实际上是跑不起来的
但这里面讲的就比较深了
但是我想跟同学讲了一个概念
就是说
其实当我们定义一个真正的一个
商业级的游戏引擎的时候
事实上这个就是这个资产的版本的compatibility
实际上是一个非常专业
非常重要的一个东西需要思考的
那这个问题怎么解呢
那我们先讲一下你可能遇到的情况
其实他讲起来也很简单
就是你会遇到两种情况
一种就是你的一个field其实被人给删掉了对吧
比如在这里面我的这个transform被人干掉了
对不对
还有一种是什么呢
唉未来我系统越做越复杂
我就越加越多
但是呢你的数据文件还放在那
你得把它打开来
对不对
那怎么办呢
其实这里面的话呢
有一个比较这个简单粗暴的做法
就比如说我们看一下荣耀怎么干呢
他很简单
他说呢我每一个资产我程序员手写版本号对吧
那我就检查了
说哎我现在已经已经升级到7号版本了
但是你的你的你的资产还是6号版本
我就知道有一个数据
你就是那个没有的
那好怎么办
我给你塞一个就是default value对吧
塞入一个一个缺省值
如果你你你的数据多了
那我就不读
你把你那个数据我虽然还读
但我不处理它
把它跳过去
这个方法实话实说啊
我个人啊不是特别敢苟同
就是我个人觉得方法处理的不好
因为这个随着一个系统有有3年
4年以上的发育的话
你会发现你要兼容的这个版本的
这个这个这个version number就越来越多越来越多
这个是很糟糕的一个方法
这里面的话给大家推荐一个做法吧
这个做法的话呢实际上是这个啊google提出来了
就google他们也遇到了这样的问题
其实我特别想
因为google它是全球可能最大的一个分布式系统
的这样的一个应用场景
那么他就肯定会遇到这种问题
因为在他的平台上要跑成百上千种
不同生态的这个软件
这些软件的话呢都是有不同的开发商开发
对不对
然后呢版本也各自有不同的频率在在在更替
然后之前的数据还会来回通讯对吧
那这个张三的软件更新了
李四的软件没有更新
网络的软件又更又又又又又又回退了好了
那这里的数据的通讯就全部完成
全部全部全部完蛋了
那么google就提出了一个叫po buffer这样的一个format
其实他的想法我个人认为又简单又好使
其实非常简单粗暴
就是说它要求你在定义每一个数据field
就是一个属性的时候
你给它生成一个unique id
这个id呢你保证它是一直单调递增就好了
这样的话就是当你的数据一直在更新的时候
我就比较说你这个id有没有发生变化
是不是很简单很好使对吧
但是呢实话实说啊
我我很想吐槽的一件事
就是他的这个就是语法定义
让我觉得真的不敢恭维你
大家看一下就上面写了
就是说哎这个string GUI d等于一
string file name等于二
哎我的天
我当时看到这个我的
因为作为一个这个这个这个有点强迫症的C加
加的这个开发者的话
我会觉得大哥你这不是让我再付这个缺省值吗
我我我觉得如果像我们这种插面空的话
或者JASON控的话
我会说你给我加个冒号
什么什么UID什么
这个这个等于一我都好一点
我都能忍
你让我这个这个feel的直接等于一
我就会觉得你是在负确认值
但是呢可能大家习惯了也就好了
他肯定我相信姑姑大大
他她这么做一定是有他的道理的
我不懂
只能说明我的水平不够
所以呢大家可能可以无视我这段点评啊
但是大家可以去学习他的这个思维方式
就是说这个方式其实非常的好
因为这个就是当你面对大量的
就是我们的一个游戏引擎啊
它实际上跟google面临的环境是有点像
因为它有大量的模块
都有不同的开发者去开发和维护他的版本变化
很快它会产生
像比如说一个像一个商业级的游戏引擎
它的数据format格式
格式可以达到几十甚至到上百种
而且呢
这每一种格式都是由不同的团队
去开发和维护的
然后但是我们的artist他在打开一个工具的时候
比如说打开一个地图编辑器的时候
他可能会同时面对几十种完全异构的数据
那我们怎么能保证这个整个工具体系的
鲁棒性的话
在这一点上就是叫这个版本兼容性的话
是一个非常重要的一个核心指标
其实在网络环境下
在分布式部署情况下
这个问题会变得更加的复杂
所以我一跟同学们讲
我就说游戏引擎是一个大型软件工程
其实这个时候大家应该有一点点感觉了对吧
你想你要伺候那个成百上千的这些
我们的艺术家
老爷我们的设计师老爷的话
实际上是要求你这个系统做的还是相当鲁邦的
那接下来的话呢又又到了
我刚才已经点到这个词了
就是如何让你的工具变得更加鲁棒一点呢
你要知道就是当我在做一个游戏引擎的时候
昨天跟大家讲就是游戏引擎
做游戏引擎是在整个游戏团队里面
大家会觉得我们的地位是不是很高诶
实际上你们错了
做游戏引擎的团队是地位最低的
为什么呢
因为我们在服务所有的人
包括程序员
因为程序员要基于游戏引擎开发游戏嘛
就是给你们举个例子吧
比如说在我们这个行业里面
如果一款游戏失败了
这个大家首先想到背锅的是谁
不是什么策划
不是美术
不是程序
一定是游戏引擎
对不起
我的游戏引擎选错了
所以我这个游戏就失败了
诶这个所以游戏引擎的话
大家如果想做游戏引擎的话
一定要有这个觉悟
就是做好背锅侠的准备对吧
那作为我们这种背锅侠呢
我们就这个非常小心谨慎
我们就说诶那既然我要背那么多锅
那我就索性这个把我这个做的再鲁棒一点对吧
这样少挨点骂
所以呢其实特别是工具链来讲的话
它的鲁棒性要求是非常高的
因为实际上游戏引擎一旦工具链出问题的话
对整个团队的影响是非常大
大家想象一下
如果你的游戏引擎工具崩了
那你几百人一上午什么事情干不了
等着你把这个bug修好
你想想看你作为一个引擎开发者
你的内心压力有多大
反正我们是亲身经历过的那种感觉
真的是如坐针毡
你会觉得欠了大家很多很多钱的感觉
所以的话呢让工具的棒易用
其实是工具链的一个非常核心的点
那作为一个游戏引擎开发商
怎么让工具变得鲁棒呢
那首先的话诶也是大家最需要的东西
就是undo redo
对这个东西听上去
其实当我们一开始在做一个工具链的时候
比如像我最早在做编辑器的时候
我会想到很多粉丝的feature
比如说我要做个很酷的这个植被
刷一刷子刷过去
山川河流都给你变出来对吧
然后呢我要做最酷的悬崖峭壁
这个这个各种各样的东西
我要做这个刮风下雨
但实际上你会发现artist跟你讲
诶大哥我刚才做了一个误操作怎么办
你把这个数据删掉
重新再来一遍对吧
你你就疯掉了
你会发现就是所有的编辑器
editor到最后最核心的功能其实就是这个安度锐度
而且呢对于游戏引擎来讲的话
安度锐度其实非常的复杂
为什么
他的就是他的很多数据编辑是correlate的
举个例子啊
比如说我现在改了一个房子的颜色
诶房子没问题对吧
我我绕着房子旁边种了一些树
也没有问题
这个时候我突然决定把地面往上拉
个这个这个34米形成了小土坡
然后这时候这个房子和树啊
它都会相应地发生变化
然后呢我看这个房子不错
我在旁边在自动释放是吧
生成一些这个DECO
就生成房子周边的那个一圈的那种诶
这个往外延拓的这种这种沙地空白地的感觉
唉这个时候当你要undo的叫你undo的时候
你会发现你有些难度会影响到其他人
比如说你首先把那房子给干了
那个旁边那个地那一圈低调可能就有问题
当你把刚才地形的山山山地调整的去改了之后
你刚才种的那些树
可能它的角度很多人都会发生变化
所以说其实在游戏引擎里面
这种undo和redo的话
彼此之间是有很深的correlation
而且很多肽
那么另外一个的话呢
就是你做的再好的工具
你都会什么呢
你都会crash
然后你crash之后
人家艺术家他这个编辑了一个小时的东西对吧
人家也不会想着去存盘
然后突然就crush掉了之后
那怎么办
那就是要你的命了
对不对
还我数据
我怎么还
我又不会画画
我又不会那个做关卡
这个时候
作为这个游戏引擎的to chain的开发者的话
实际上这个东西就是我们一个非常需要花时间
去想明白的一个一个问题
怎么去解决
诶
幸好我们有伟大的一个design pattern来支持我们
这个问题呢
其实在这个软件体系里面是一个will study problem
就是一个被研究的非常透的问题
大家今天用word对吧
用POWERPOINT写PPT
然后用word写文档
你们知道就是当你挂了之后
你再打开的时候
他会告诉你有个recovery
对不对
然后呢redo难度都会非常方便
其实呢它就是一个非常标准的叫command
这个pattern
也就是说我们把用户所有的操作
把它分解成无数的小的command
然后呢我这小的command它就会逐渐累加
然后呢它会非常原子化的头发
但注意啊
这里面讲一个细节
是不是每一个用户的操作对应一个common
实际上有的时候用户的一步操作
我们会分解成好多好多common的
这是有一定道理的
就是我们尽量让come on的原子化
那么这个时候呢
我们会把这些command定时的存到我们的磁盘上
这样万一我系统挂了的时候
我从磁盘上去找对吧
当用户突然响了
诶
我要去undo的时候
这其实就是啊我们叫做简单的说法
叫做这个revoke和invoke
就是暗度学术的做法
我们叫in revoke
那好那我把刚才内部操作给回退出去
所以呢这个pattern的话呢
也是非常符合人的直觉
但是今天如果同学们要加自己的to chain的时候
我会非常建议在很早期的阶段
就把这一套结构架好
因为你这套结果一开始的话
你在早期架的时候
你随着你的工具链的功能越来越复杂的话
你在不断的丰富和完善它
那你这个系统就会比较稳定
你千万不要就to change
你做的已经比较大了
你再开始做这套系统
那我告诉你这个事情非常的痛苦对吧
因为我们自己是经历过这个痛苦的
我们知道这个事很麻烦对吧
那真的是一天上百个bug扑面而来的感受
我们大家想象一下
这个是压力很大的好
那么其实呢common definition
比大家想象的要简单的多了
最简单的描述就是每个command
你要给他一个UEID
我待会解释为什么你要有UEID对吧
然后呢你要有一串data
然后这当然得command
你要它是一个interface
就是你每一种的command要自己去定义的
那么接下来最核心的就是两个函数什么呢
一个叫invoke
Invoke
就是诶我这个come on要去执行它对吧
还有一个函数叫什么呢
叫river这个函数我退出了
我不干了
我退回去一步
那么还有两个函数呢
大家可能被注意不到
教serialize
Deserialize
但是大家仔细想想
这个其实也是有道理的
就是说哎我把这个command我存到磁盘上
怎么存对吧
我从磁盘加载怎么加载
当然有的时候呢
其实我们一些比较多的这些come on的操作的话
我们甚至会存在自拍
就是在内存文件中
甚至会存在内存dB中都是有可能的
所有的serialization和DESSERATION其实很重要
还有一点
这个待会我们在下节课会讲的
就是说诶如果我们要做协同编辑的时候
这个东西是不是也是有用的好
那我们接着往下讲
就是为什么我们要一个UE对吧
为什么每个come on我们要给个编号呢
其实这个编号呢首先它是唯一的累加的
当你这种command在不断的累加唯一性的时候
大家意味着什么
这是不是就意味着一种诶隐含的序列
这个东西为什么这么重要呢
因为当我在进行回退就是revoke的时候
当我进行recovery的时候
我是希望他的执行要严格地遵循原始的顺序
这就是大家知道就是在真正编辑操作的时候
大家会知道很多操作
如果你执行的顺序不一样的话
它的结果是不是会完全不一样对吧
这个大家很好理解吧
所以的话呢其实UID就是一个保证这个顺序的
就是单调递增的一个核心的一个点
这一点的话在写common系统的时候
大家一定要注意
那么另外一个的话呢
其实在这个common系统中的话呢
一般不是common系统自己写的
而是什么呢
是由那个数据自身提供了这个标准的思路
ALIZATION和第四人类线的方法
这样也就相当于比如说我一个GO对吧
我要说aleue object
我加一个GO
那好那这个机构资深
它要提供诶
我把我当前在内存中
我这个角色
比如说我这个character全部的状态
能够series下来的这个方法
那么come on
系统就说OK我现在决定创建一个角色好
这个角色所有的数据调查
那个角色数据就是character
那个GO的那个里面的就是game object
你们的serialization的方法
他把这数据给存下来了
所以这个呢也是
当我们去实现这套common系统的时候
它也可以变相的逼着我们
把整个引擎的系统都写得非常的干净
这样能让我们的引擎
所有的操作都能够原子化好
那么其实呢就是在command系统里面啊
其实目前人大家总结下来其实就是三类的
command是最标准的
第一类呢我们认为就at
就是其实你就创建一个诶一个对象对吧
它可能是个极有可能是别的东西
第二类就是我们把一个对象给删了
第三个呢我们对对象的一个值进行改变
就是改变对象的一个field
比如说哎我改变一个一个对象的
它的速度
一个大小一个field
其实你会发现
无论多么复杂的这样的一个API系统
用这三类的command基本上就能表达了
其实大家去研究
如果有有空去研究一下
那个就是那个文本编辑器
其实文本编辑器它的所有的revoke invoke的话
基本上就是用这三类操作就能解决了
这是非常了不起的一件事啊
就是增加一个text
删除一个text和呃
更新一个text
基本上就能解决
这其实也很有道理的一件事
所以呢其实这个实际上就是我们的工具链的
一个基础的开发的逻辑
你发现没
我讲了这么多
没有讲一句话
这个到底工具链怎么写
为什么呢
因为每个工具的写法都是不一样的
但是呢大家这个foundation比如像S的系统
像这个command系统
像这些这个GUI的体系要答对
实际上大家是在做图称最重要的基础
这也是就是让大家不要去急着写
我经常看到有些同学会说
诶我做了一个编辑器
做的特别帅
你看我这个地图可以拖动什么东西
做的很好
是的
你这个东西单独做一个是很容易
你做十几个功能没有问题
但是你真的开始面对一个editor
你面对上百工的
然后你有十几个不同的editor的时候
你会发现如果前面的这些事情没做对的话
你会非常痛苦
好接下来呢就是为什么这件事情那么重要
就是因为我们要构建的不是一个单一的工具
我们构建的是什么呢
是一个two chain
对工具链
我们有很多的工具在一起好不好
他们彼此之间是有血缘关系的
要彼此通讯
彼此联系
互相说的话
互相能听得懂
这就是一个很挑战的一件事儿
那么其实呢这个to chain就像我前面讲的
它其实是面对完全不一样的user对吧
那每个月的需求不一样
那么如果我每一个to啊他单独去写的话
实际上这个工具链它是没有可扩展性
也没有可维护性的
因为这些数据全部都是异构的
大学刚才我虽然我讲了很多ACS怎么去定义
对不对
但是这asset之间每一个工序长得都不一样
那我们彼此之间我的编辑器怎么写啊对吧
我的我我
我一会儿要编这个这个这个一个一个点光源
我一会儿要编一个角色动作
我一会要编一个场景的这个低调的分布
那么这个其实每个数据我都知道怎么定义
但它彼此之间是异构的
所以呢这里面呢就引入了一个非常重要的一
个思维方法
就是我从各种各样的这个都要心中找出共性
那么当我们打开一个数据的时候
你会发现诶其实再复杂的数据
它都是有很多简单的building block构成的
比如说我们去描述一个点光源的时候
你其实有的是什么
很多时候都是诶他的一个vector3的
一个它的坐标
它的点点的位置
它的方向也是vector3诶
他有一个什么呢
它有一个颜色对吧
各种各样的颜色
比如说NB的DIFFICKER
对不对
这其实都是一些非常基础的一些building block
在这里面我们就观察到一件事情
就是说其实任何复杂的数据
我们可以把它描述成一些简单数据的集
这个像什么呢
就像我们现在物理学
虽然这个世界非常的复杂
但是我们会找到基础的原子
108种原子
我就可以通过它的组合去表达
这个世界的任何一种物质对吧
那么好
如果这些原则我们来找到
接下来我们需要什么呢
哎我们需要一个东西
这个东西叫什么呢
我们叫做schema schema呢
其实我觉得这是这个词很有意思啊
就我这是这个标题
是我自己写的
就是a description structure
就是说是一种描述的结构
用一种更简单的话去讲
就是说啊就像刚才我举的原子这个例子
那么这个schema更像什么呢
更像分子式诶
这个有点意思了吧
就是他描述的这个物质是由哪些原子构成的
就像今天我要定义一个长方形啊
第一个长方体其实它的描述就是三个量
就float x y z代表了它的长宽高
对不对
如果我要表示表示一个圆的话
其实我就一个量float2他就表示出来了
那么这个float加一个东西
这个结构就是一个schema
那你按照这个schema写出的数据
它就是一致的
所以schema系统的话呢
是游戏工具链最核心的一个底层
就是说所有的在游戏这个工具链里面流流转的
这样的一个数据的话
它都是要用schema统一的描述和定义的
这样的话我的数据彼此才能解读
比如说我一个啊
比如说地图编辑器打开了一个角色
这个橘右进来
那角色他如有
如果有了CHEMA
我就知道哦
这个character name叫什么
这个character的这个这个这个声
它的放缩是多少
他用的是哪个mesh
他用的是哪个动画
那这样的一个角色一拖到我的编辑器里的时候
我编辑器在那个panel里面就会出现他的名字
他的动画
然后呢你点那个动画的播放诶
这个角色他自己可以就可以动起来了
这些代码全部不是他的code
它全是通过schema告诉各种各样的工具
你该怎么去理解这个数据
它每一个数据的语义到底是什么
那么好
那么其实呢就是说
schema是一个非常重要的表达
因为我用这些简单的building block
我性能表达一些high level的数据
举个例子
比如说我们的一条curve curve是很重要的
在游戏引擎状况
就比如说我们在粒子系统中
我们怎么去表达这个一个色带的
随着时间的变化对吧
那我可以把它RGB通道变成客户
那其实呢在schema里面你可以表现成什么呢
哎表达成一组这个点的这个集合
那么在scar你就可以表达出来
那么其实你用这个最简单的元素
用schema去构建出了各种各样
你想要的HILIP这个数据
那么就是说其实schema呢它本身是非常复杂的
但我记得里面给大家讲几个概念
就是说第一schema的话呢
你要设计它的时候
它需要有继承关系
这也就是说
这个其实这个是非常像我们高级语言的
这个类的派生继承
因为schema本身就描述了一种类嘛
比如说我们定义的一个东西叫做啊
人人的schema有什么对吧好
我有他的身高
他的他的他的长相
他的这个这个这个这个体重等等
所有的数据好
这是我的第一个一类数据叫什么呢
叫军人好
这个军人这个schema其实你不用再重写一遍
你其实可以从人的这个schema派生出来
你再加两个field
比如说它的战斗力是多少对吧
它的血量是多少
对不对
这些数据你就有了对吧
你再派生一个
比如叫商人
商人送人派生的唉
你可以说他有钱有多少
他的这个经商能力是多少
其实这个schema的话呢
实际上就非常像我们的高级语言
你们的角色对应
所以在这里面的实现有两种流派
有一类流派
它真的就是用高级语言直接定义的哦
待会我会讲到
那么还有一个呢就是在schema里面的话呢
我们要允许他去互相reference data
就在前面EEE我也讲过了
就是reference data非常重要
比如说我去定义一个车的描述的时候
我就会说有些field的
它是指向了另外一个资产和数据对吧
所以说其实我们这些asset之间的关联的话
有一个是动态的
就是数据之间真实的就是S之间关联
还有一种呢就是类型之间的关联
你可以看到一个比如说我去表达一个角色
这个角色呢它会引用到一堆的文件
比如说网格啊
动画呀对吧
行为数啊这些文件好诶
我在这个网格
这个就是我的这个这个mesh这个文件里面
又会影响到什么呢
哎纹理啊
贴图啊
这些文件就可以全部的这个就会引用到
所以这个也是非常有意思的
就是说其实我们在数据定义层面
也会形成一个关系数
所以当我们在这个游戏引擎构建的时候
首先大家一定要构建一个schema系统
第二呢你在设计schema系统的时候呢
我会强烈推荐大家去建立
schema之间可以去继承
这样的话
我可以不断的去去派生出各种各样的变种
第二个的话
在中间我要允许用户去定义
各种各样的数据应用
那么刚才提到
就是说schema的定义它其实非常像高级语言
所以呢它就产生了两个流派
有一类流派呢
他就是诶直接用那个类似脚本的这样的语言
或者用XML用什么语言
JASON其实也可以
我就直接定义了schema
OK完事
这个这个数据很干净对吧
那么的话呢他用一套方法
直接把这个东西反射成这个引擎的代码
让引擎直接根据schema
就知道怎么去读资产文件了
包括资产文件怎么读
怎么写
怎么编辑
它全部自动生成对吧
这个地方我就不展开了
其实这里应该画一张更更有意思的一个图
还有一种方法是什么呢
其实就是大家非常熟悉的
比如像unreal的做法是什么
我其实定义了一个C加加高级语言的一个类
但是呢我通过一个红去描述唉
说我这个东西是一个matter的一个数据
我可以反射的好诶
我接下来就这个我这个对应的数据有
然后这里面
但是呢它里面定义了很多变量
对不对
我也不用所有的变量
我看见这几个变量
我是希望他在那个就是文件中是有反射的对吧
包括一些方法我都能反射
其实大家回想一下
我们的QA引擎用的是哪个方法对吧
我们pk ue引擎用的其实是defined in the code
其实我们跟AL的方法是一样的对吧
但其实我们另外一种话
我们也写过哪种方法
哪个好哪个坏呢
啊这个说句实话
我是很难给出评判的
因为我个人觉得这两种方法各有利弊
那首先比如想这个用stand alone的文件去定义呢
它的好处是什么呢
就是说他非常非常好理解
而且呢这个就是说他真的是彻底的
把这个数据的定义和工程实践彻底剥离开了
但是它比较麻烦的一件事情是什么呢
第一个就是说它需要有一个就是自动的代码
渲染器
叫代码生成器
根据你的chema passing生成各种各样的代码
它很容易出现一个问题
就是说你的schema版本可能是过新的
或者过老的
但是呢你的引擎二进制呢可能跟它版本不一致
当然我们有很多方法可以检测啊
比如说他发现4K码是错的
那引擎就拒绝启动
对吧
死给你看
那你说啊
我知道了
我schema文件配错了
但有的时候对于非技术性的同学
他就觉得这个事特别的蛋疼
所以这两个之间版本不兼容啊
实际上是这种方法是经常会遇到的问题
那么第二个呢就是经常会遇到的问题
就是说在这种文本方式的话呢
我很难定义
就是说比如说这一个人这个角色
其实他有很多的接口
它可以做很多动作的
比如说我们叫做API
那你其实你没有办法去定义的对吧
但其实当我们定义一个东西的描述的时候
其实我还可以描述它能做什么事情
那这个时候呢啊实际上这个分开的文本方式会
其实他可以做
你真的强行去写
通过反射
我把函数名写在那对吧
我在加C加加你反射一下
我总是能找得到的
对不对
但这个事情就显得有点笨
所以一般来讲
如果你真的把它剥开了的话
我们真的把它彻头彻尾的变成一个数据的定义
那么这一点的话呢
反而在引擎就是用code代码直接定义4K码
反而是有它的优势
就是说它可以直接的
就是说把一些方法也包进去
另外一个的话呢
因为它它的数据定义和它的引擎是高度匹配的
所以你一编译完之后
他整个就一套全全下来了
所以他不太会出现两个版本不兼容
但是他的问题是什么呢
他的问题就是比较复杂
就是经常特别比如举个例子吧
比如说像那个虚幻引擎
就大家用很多
很多使用者会发现一个问题
就是说当你去真正去动这些引擎代码
改变一些数据结构定义的时候
经常已经就死给你看了对吧
编译说诶就挂了
或者编译可编的过
但是跑起来就挂了
崩了之后你就要花很长时间去debug
而且如果像我刚才讲的
如果你的工具链炸掉了的话
那么这个对整个团队的影响就会非常大
当然这个我们会通过一些UE
UE来来尽可能的覆盖嘛
所以的话呢一般来讲就是在code中定义的schema
对于这种巨型系统来讲的话呢
它对你工程的稳定性和架构的鲁棒性
要求是蛮高的
否则的话特别容易把整个引擎加
工具链一起搞死的这种情况
所以的话呢两种方法你很难说好坏
但各有利弊
所以啊同学们可以根据自己的选择去选择
那我们这次做PICO的时候的话呢
呃我们是想教给大家一些有意思的概念
所以我们就选择了这个就是这个这个
这个这个就是again的这个方法
这个方法的话呢
其实大家一直很想知道那个matter pasa
怎么work的嘛
实际上你你看懂了metaphor这个机制的话
你就不会觉得像虚幻引擎的反射
有那个就很难理解了对吧
其实它的核心底层逻辑是非常接近的好
那其实呢就是说
其实我们schema也反映了一件事情是什么呢
就是说同样一个数据在我的工具链中
在我的整个这个游戏的生产体系里面
它有三张脸
他的第一张脸呢实际上是给硬盘的
就是我存到硬盘中了
刚才我讲了
你可以存成二进制的
你也可以存成这个
就是那个文本格式的对吧
反正呢它这个它的存储空间很大
随便你怎么存都可以
但是实际上如果一个真正商业级游戏的时候呢
我们还是会很在意它的存储空间
因为啊
比如说你几十个G和上百个G的体验
是完全不一样的
而且那个如果上百G的文本加载那个速度
那可是非常感人的
这个这个应该没有任何一个商业级的游戏公司
会这么干
那么在内存中呢没有的选择
他一定是二进制的
但是呢它的核心都是什么呢
就是以这个处理为目标的
第三个还有一张脸是什么呢
哎在整个工具中给用户使用的
它也是第三张脸
那么在这个就是说那个内存中的话呢
我们一切是以这个数据以高效处理为目标的
所以说呢我的数据结构定义的时候
都是为了各种数学变化
比如说加减乘除
比如说拷贝添加删除速度快为为他的依据
那么在这个内存中的话呢
就是在存储中的话呢
我们一般会尽量以节约存储空间
这里面举个例子
比如说像那个一个矩阵
我们的投影矩阵
很多时候呢
其实你只虽然它是个4×4的矩阵啊
但实际上你能用到的一般是四
4×3或者是3×3
那哦33×3加一
那这个时候呢
我们一般就会做很多数据的压缩处理
这个也是一个非常重要的一个方法
但是最有意思的我们认为是工具的这个view
工具这个view
那么这里面讲一个细节
就是说我们实际上schema定义的
比如说一个color
你看到的就是三个
比如说整数
但实际上在工序里面
我们就会把它变成A大家可以看到的颜色
这边你看到的是几个不同颜色的标记对吧
实际上你在点开来之后
你可以看到一个
非常符合人的理解的一个调色板
这就是工具最核心要解决的问题
就是我要对不同的人展开不同的view
举个简单的例子啊
比如说在设置一个引擎数据的时候
很多时候我们会设置角度角度
在引擎中
一般我们用弧度
为什么呢
在所有的那个数学库中
它的max
比如说sign cos
tan的这种计算全部是基于弧度的对吧
因为你们如果理解计算机里面怎么算
是数学运算的时候
你就知道弧度是最基础的计算方法
但是唉你跟artist讲说
你输入一个3/4派二次
怎么算不就封掉了嘛
对不对
那这个时候实际上我们输出的全是欧拉角
比如说270度对吧
180度
360度
45度
这时候大家人人类就非常好理解
其实类似这样的东西啊
在整个工具链里面非常重要
这就是我们在设计工具链的时候
一定要把这个数据变成一个
人类可以理解的一个view
那同时的话呢有些数据它非常的复杂
怎么办
我们可以提供两种UE
一种view是default
简单的view就是我只放必要的
你可以调的数据
有些地方呢我会放一些比较丰富的展开的
这样的一个view
其实也都在解决这样的一个问题
所以这个其实在做工具链的时候是非常重要的
这就意味着当我们在第一schema的时候
我们对于每一种数据类型
实际上我们要提供一个可以为他定制
不同view的这样的一种能力
这也是当我们再去做to chain的时候
很重要的一种方法
那么最后呢给大家讲一个就是大家很小啊
这这不是最后就是哎也是个很酷的名字
就是WYSIWYG对吧
现在是个缩写
满天飞的东西
就是大家看见这个肯定会觉得哇
这什么玩意儿这么长
这么诡异对吧
不有没有YYDS那么传神
但这个呢其实是一个很酷的一句话
叫what do you see is
What you get
就是所见即所得
这可以理解成
就是说
在我们构建整个工具体系的一个核心精神
那为什么这件事情很重要呢
因为其实工具啊对于我们的这个artist来讲
它是一个非常重要的一个
就是啊一个一个preview的一个东西
就是说其实最早以前很多游戏引擎的工具
它是独立去写的
早期的时候
但是为什么后来artist不满意
因为我不能够接受
就是说我在你的编辑器里调出的效果
比如说它的光光照
它的材质质感
这个人物的动作和我在真实游戏
跑起来的东西是不一样的
如果这两个是不一样的话
那美术的校呢艺术家的效能将极度的下降
所以说他要求在这个工具链里面
实现一比一的百分之百还原的一个preview
就是我要知道这东西讲什么呀
否则这个东西材质我没法做
那么对于designer来讲是什么呢
工具链是一个非常重要的一个
game played prototype的一个工具
它要在这边最快速的方法去prototype它的工具
比如像这里面
比如说诶我快速的决定加一组墙去阻断
这时候我要感受一下
我这个人玩家拿到这把枪的时候
我射击的感觉
我的整个能看到什么
我不能看见什么
这个地方设计师也是需要我最快的速度
最低的成本去尝试不同的
比如说关卡的layout
这就是就是大家无论是设计设计好还是美
艺术家也好
对工具链提出的要求就是我希望所见即所得
那之前怎么做呢
就这里面要讲的就是工具链
在整个引擎里面的架构方法
其实最早期的架构呢
我们一般是把工具链独立放在一边
因为大家知道工具链的逻辑是非常复杂的
它有很多的编辑啊
你想象一下
比如说一个简单的物理
你对它进行拖动和移动操作
他知道那个简单的那个那个叫那个小旋钮
旋钮叫gadget
实际上协调的逻辑很复杂
为什么它要实实现那种自动吸附啊
然后呢旋转的时候要按整数角
比如五度与旋转呢
而且自动alignment
而且你这个快捷键切换在旋转那个平移放缩
来回切换
而且你还要自动对齐
大家如果用过vile
用过word这些软件
就知道这些细节其实非常的多
这里面有很多很脏的代码
而且非常的这个special
所以你最自然的感觉就是诶
我需要保持一个非常clean的我的引擎对吧
那你呢可以给我共享一些代码
OK但是你的工具链这些脏的
比如说如何编辑一个动画
如何做这个这个行为树
如何去去管理这种资产的
比如说做这种摆放这些东西
你全部给独立的
它是一个独立的工具链
但是这种架构呢它会出一个比较严重的问题
就是什么呢
就是说诶你特别是在artist那一趴
真的所见非所得
那么对于designer来讲的话呢
你虽然能够帮我快速摆放
但是我没有办法直接在游戏中去play
一模一样的东西
所以这种方法现在的话呢
在商业级引擎中用的已经越来越少了
现在大家真正用的比较多的架构是什么呢
就是诶我把工具整个架在游戏之上
说白了就是我在工具里面直接调用的是游戏
大家首先想到的是什么
就是场地图编辑器
对不对
我在地图编辑器里面
我可以直接编辑这个场景
然后呢哎我一键就可以去play
那我肯定需要这个
但实际上我给大家讲
比如说不只是地图地图编辑器啊
比如说我做特效编辑器
那我希望呢他一上来也是游戏引擎好的
OK不好意思
他也是游戏引擎
那么其实的话呢
包括像那个就是比如说大家像动画编辑器对吧
还有一些cinematic
就是比如说像艾瑞亚
你们最著名的sequencer这个编辑器
其实下面跑的就是一个游戏
那这样的好处是什么呢
就是说哎我调好的材质
我做好的动作
我调好的光
我设计好了一个特效
我我在游戏中看到的东西
和在编辑器里看的东西是一模一样的
所以这个方法呢它本身开发起来啊
其实从设计架构上要求是蛮高的
因为要求游戏引擎
它能够向上兼容编辑器的需求
但是的话呢它带来的好处
特别是对于生产效率的帮助是巨大的
所以说在现代商业级游戏里面的话呢
我们一般都会采用这个架构
包括PICO
其实用的也是这个架构对吧
叫硬件这个模型
那这个应变模型的话呢
它实际上就会要求在引擎的RUNTIME上面
我们要加一层asha thing
就是编辑的这个场景
这里面和管理我所有编辑的整个逻辑
这些这些
比如说UEI编辑相关的各种各样的
中间的这种数据和状态
然后呢再往上呢
我会生成我独立的编辑的UEI
就刚才我讲的GI
它这个体系就往一层层上去了
所以这个结构其实你维护起来的话呢
是比较复杂
但是呢我们会给同学们讲的
就是说如果你们想做一个好的
这个就是游戏的工具链的话
我们会非常强烈推荐大家用这个模型
当然未来这个结构被淘汰了呢也是有可能的
肯定有人发明更好的结构了
目前为止的话
行业你大概会觉得这个结构是最好的
因为它能真正实现我们的所见即所得
那么这个时候的话呢
另外一个很重要的概念是什么呢
就是playing editor
就说这个呢也是符合这个
特别是对于啊其实不仅对设计师吧
其实对艺术家来讲也很重要
就是说呃我做好了一个关卡
实际上我去编他的时候
和我真的去玩它的时候感觉是不一样的
对不对
比如说我作为一个关卡设计师
我做IPS对吧
我做了个关卡
我想感受一下我在里面打枪穿的感觉
所以我希望一键就能play这个功能
叫做API
就playing editor
那么APIE呢
实际上是现代游戏引擎很核心的一个需求
但APIE呢有两个实现的方法
第一个呢是我在编辑器里面直接就可以play了
对吧
就playing editor
还有一种呢是什么呢
就是当你去点这个API按钮的时候
我会形成一个专门的叫API mod
你可以理解成
就是把我现在编辑的所有的东西再拷贝一份
我启动一个游戏
然后呢在里面再跑一份
那你显然第二种方法是不是很麻烦
对不对
第一种方法是不是更简单
实际上的话呢这两种方法各有利弊
比如说就是我直接在editor里面去跑的话
它其实这个结构就比较比较简单
而且呢它是非常容易实现的
就等于等于说我把编辑的状态
直接就可以无缝的去play了
比如说我们的皮克勒小引擎
就是这个模型
大家在我上次跟大家讲的就是学了小引擎
有个特点
就是你现在如果这个角色你跑跑跑
跑到一某一帧的时候
你突然说诶我要编辑了
你会发现在编辑器里面
这个角色他就停在那个位置
他就在做那个动作
这其实就是playing editor这个结构
这个结构呢它的优点是什么呢
非常的简单
但是它的缺点是什么呢
诶editing的这个数据和游戏的这个引擎的数据呢
它有的时候会混到一起去
混到一起会出什么问题呢
给大家讲一个简单的情况
就是比如说我们editor里面有大量的数据对吧
它会污染游戏play的逻逻辑的数据
但是理论上我们会认为分开对不对
但你写这么复杂的系统
有的时候你分布的分布分布的特别清楚
那这个时候我们可能会出现一个问题
就是诶这个玩法在editor模式里面没有bug
没有问题
但是呢当我编程独立的游戏的时候
诶编程那个release版的时候
突然你发现了遇到了一些问题
反之亦然
就可能有一个问题诶
你在这个就是editor版里面有问题
但是在那个就是那个在游戏里跑团又没有问题
但这个其实你可以认为是个bug
但实际上确实你很多时候那么复杂的系统啊
你很难把它加在临清
所以呢就是比如说像unreal
他采取的模型是什么呢
就playing piano word
就是说我把现在所有的editing的世界
整个把这个物体再在一个pie
那个一个一个沙盒里面全部重新创造一遍
我把环境全部重置一下
然后呢
这个时候我在这个APIE的mod里面去玩这个游戏
相当于我多花了一些内存
给这个世界做了一个单独的player的分身
这个逻辑呢其实它能解决这个问题
而且呢它本身更能模拟游戏的单独的一个环境
其实呢这个结构呢
我个人认为就是
如果你要做一个大型的复杂的游戏的话
我倒会建议这种模型
这种模型的话虽然你会浪费很多内存
但现在内存还好对吧
我们像我们电脑配个60多G的内存
也能配得出来
实际上的话呢是一个比较好的一个方法
所以的话呢大家在下这个游戏引擎
工具链的时候
大家可以在这两个模型中自己去选择
就是选择适合你自己的模型
如果你做的是个小型的
比如说啊不是特别复杂的一个游戏引擎的话
那我觉得就是那个playing editor其实基本上就够用了
但是如果你真的希望能够商用级的
给很多很多人用起来的话
而且面对是个复杂的一个游戏系统的话
我们会建议你会考虑就是playing API的这个模型
会更好一点
那么对吧
这个这是我们真正的最后1part了
就是one more thing了对吧
plugin对
这个真的是one more thing
为什么呢
因为讲到这儿
基本上你所有的工具该怎么做
你都知道怎么做
那为什么我们还要做plugin呢
因为是这样的
就是说其实啊我们做一个游戏引擎
你要知识的游戏是千变万化
完全不受你控制
你根本想象不到
作为一个游戏引擎开发者
你根本不知道你的用户会用它做什么样的游戏
然后它需要什么样的功能
我们我们从来不会自大的认为
我们做出了所有我们用户需要的工具
这是不可能的
所以我们一定要允许我们的用户
他自由的开发各种各样的工具
比如像这里面这是UE的一个插件对吧
是一个第三方开发者
他可以自由的开发一个完整的一个
水体交互的插件
你水的这种各种各样的属性啊
它都可以在里面去调
他怎么去模拟
怎么去仿真对吧
其实这个实际上奠定了现代游戏的
我们叫stability
就是它的可扩展性其实非常的重要
那么其实插件呢实际上是现代商业引擎
最重要的一种开发能力
所以我们经常在讲的就是
现代游戏引擎的本质是什么
我认为是个up
就是它是个平台
在这上面的话可以集成各种各样的功能
这都是由第三方开发者去开发的
举个例子
比如说大家去打开3D max maya对吧
比如像胡迪尼
像那个ZBRUSH
其实呢它都有大量的插件
就是提供了丰富的功能给大家
就是能快速的完成功能
因为能适应你千变万化的需求
所以插件是个很重要的一个系统
那么插件它对于我们整个引擎的要求是什么
特别工具链引擎
实际上我们需要提供大量的API
这些API的话呢能够开放给第三方开发者
他通过我们的接口能够注册各种各样
他想要的功能
并且定制他的药药的UEI
然后呢能对这个世界进行自己所想要的偏激
那么其实呢在这里面的话
这个这个API的设计就非常的重要
比如说我们要在我们的to b上加一个API
E的按钮
对不对
那我就要说诶
我知道你的API我要注册
把我的这个plugin注册进去
然后呢把我的按钮创建进去
这个时候我的pluck manager就会帮我
把整个这个世界给构建起来
那么其实今天当我们去设计一个游
戏引擎的时候
其实你的可扩展性
plugin的这个方便的能力
其实我们认为是个刚需吧
就是说所以的话呢就是比如像这里面
就是说你的arrow ue里面去
你家加入在它
在它的主MANUE中加入加入一个你想要定制的menu
其实是非常简单的
这个地方的话就是现在的成熟的商业引擎的话
知识方面发展的真的是非常的好
同学们如果想真的想做引擎往前走的话
我会非常建议大家去向这些引擎去学习
看看它怎么去提供这些接口
让我们的这个引擎变得真的有可扩展性
那么这也反过来啊
对我们的整个引擎架构提出了一个要求
就是说你要尽可能把你的各种功能API化
你自己的这个编辑器功能
比如说我们做一个level editor
我想做地编
我想做产品编辑
我想做自动grouping
做prefab
我尽量通过调用这些API的方式组合起来的
那这样的话呢
当别人去开发我们这个引擎的插件的时候
我们彼此是平等的对吧
你用插件
我也用插件
那这样的话
就是说他至少不会受到太强的这样一个限制
所以的话呢这也是就是说现代游戏引擎的话
在做架构的时候
一定对它的可扩展性
对于他未来的这个无限的扩张的很兼容性的话
提出了一个非常高的一个架构性需求
所以同学们如果励志啊想做游戏引擎
大家肯定会希望我说我
我我知道各种各样很很厉害的算法对吧
我会做很多很多很多的效果
但是我希望同学们意识到一件事
就是说做现代游戏引擎
其实它是一个软件工程学的一个问题
然后呢它最核心的东西就是你要搭一个平台
能够让成百上千甚至上万甚至上10万
这些优秀的工程师
这个创造者和你一起来工作
这样的话你的这个平台才可能会成功
所以的话呢
这个就是我想
就是当我们第一章讲基础工具的话
我最后想跟大家讲的就是可扩展性
是工具的一个很核心的一个诉求
那以上呢就是我今天的这个
就是这个报告的内容
那今那个按照我们的惯例
那我们最后可以和大家分享一下
我们的一些reference
就是我们找到了一些
就是在准备这篇课件的时候
我们准备了一些参考文献
那接下来的话呢
就是也感谢一下我们课程组的小伙伴
大家真的是非常的辛苦
非常的感谢
其实哈昨天夜里两三点钟大家还在搞
然后今天是到最后大概不到30分钟吧
我们才把今天的课程定下来
之前的话真的所有人头发皮都已经快抓没了
都快都快抓掉了吧
所以说压力其实非常大
但是希望同学们能对我们的工作满意好了
那大家有没有什么问题问我们关于这节课哇
这个第一个问题是问的很很很大啊
就是工具链开发需要的能力是什么啊
其实这个这个问题是蛮有意思的
我个人的理解啊
就是工具链开发第一个需要的能力
就是说你对游戏的这个基本的制作
有一个基本的理解
你最好有时间可以参与一些游戏的真实的开发
你真实看到就是设计师啊
艺术家怎么去工作的
这样你能理解就特别理解我前面讲的那句话
就是但他大大家的这个思维方式
真的差别非常非常大
很有意思的
但是每个人都是非常合理的对吧
那么第二个的话呢
就是说你对软件架构
软件工程特别感兴趣
你并不一定需要知道很多很精深的算法
但是呢你要有非常好的这个软件系统
架构师的这种思维方式
因为工具链最核心的是软件架构
就是说一个功能
你用你有十种不同的方法做出来
但是好的真的只有那一两种
为什么
因为好的方法它在未来有真正的可扩展性
所以的话呢我觉得就是说
如果你有一颗励志做软件架构师的心
然后呢你本身又对游戏很感兴趣
我觉得你就可以成为一个非常好的
工具链开发的这样的一个一个开发者
好还有没有问题
诶这个能再说一遍web前端什么
唉这个问题问的很有意思了
就是女同学问我说
工具链用外部前端做的多不多
诶这个是一个非常前沿的一个讨论啊
其实我自己现在也没有下最后的结论
就是我们内部已经做了很多场讨论
首先的话呢现在工具链的话呢
用web前端的好像还不多
比如像大家很熟悉的
比如像aa unity对吧
包括像一些其他的事件引擎
但是呢随着现在外部
比如现H5越来越强大对吧
包括外部的开发效率越来越高
懂的人越来越多
其实我自己现在也一直在思考
就是说基于web的这样的一个前端的这样的一个
工具的开发的话
是不是也是一个为了很好的一个方向
因为确实它的底层逻辑
底层结构很多东西是很接近的
特别是基于刚才那个就是说啊
就是那个in game mode的这种方法的做工具链
其实你最比较复杂的东西
我们是全部交给了引擎来处理吗
那其实跟用户的交互
比如那些UEI对吧
那些逻辑衣服逻辑用web前端的方法去做的话
其实效率说不定还是挺高的
所以这一点的话呢
我现在更prefer就是它是一个open question
如果同学们对这事情有兴趣的话
我非常希望大家能够拉我们的教研组
那个课程组
我们一起讨论这个
我去我我我很想把它变成一个RNG的课题
说不定我们可以去外部技术
做出一个完全不一样的
那个一个工具链体系出来
对啊
比如说我们拿PICO下手
对不对
我们PO真正的工具链体系
可以全部web的技术去做一做
我们看看这里面有没有什么坑
因为确实确实啊就是这种专业的游戏软件啊
专业的软件选型的时候
很多时候有很多很性感的技术在那边诱惑我们
但是很多时候大家会啊考虑到
就是很多的工程上的不确定性
因为一旦一个决定下了之后
它的成本是非常高的
所以我们会比较谨慎
但是呢这毫不妨碍我们大胆的去想象一下
用一些前沿的技术去表达
哇这个问题就问得更有意思
有同学问我说协同编辑有没有很好的实现
那首先的话呢以目前行业来看
我觉得实现的还在一个早期阶段
包括像aria five
最近的它最大的卖点就是协同编辑嘛对吧
也提出了很多的概念
那么那但是的话呢我觉得就是首先内容的话
我们会在下一节课跟大家简单的讲一下
就是协同编辑怎么去怎么去实现
如果大家有兴趣的话
其实你就算基于PICO引擎哈
你都可以做一个非常简单的
协同编辑的一个实验
这个当然了
我不会把它做成作业
因为这个话有点有点难的
但是的话呢就是说呃我认为协同编辑这件事情
它的重要性也是一个在非常快速的提升
包括大家的方案也会越来越成熟
我个人很相信大概在5年左右吧
协同编辑这个问题
其实会得到一个非常好的一个解决
那么这里面它的基础理论已经基本成熟了
接下来就是大量的工程问题需要解决
因为无论任何一个商业级的游戏引擎啊
现在都是千万行代码的这样规模
所以呢它是一个很复杂的一个系统
你让它全面的支持协同编辑的话
那么你又不想又想保证这些功能不会丢失的话
其实在工程上的挑战
比如很多向前兼容的这些问题的话
其实还是蛮复杂的
举个例子
比如说大家都觉得word很厉害对吧
word实际上是啊
非常成熟的一个一个一个文字编辑系统
那么但是我们一旦把它word云化
让大家协同编辑
你会发现他被迫要做很多的减法
包括这个系统
我们也看到在过去几年就发展得非常快
那今天的话我们用各种各种网上的这个
协同编辑软件
那么现在感觉已经越来越顺手了
大家看到这个过程的话
可能需要三到5年的迭代和完善
但直到今天的话
你在本地区编辑word的那种强大性
易用性还是会超过协同编辑的那个网上那个word
其实呢这一点其实很能反映我们的游戏引擎
将来要面临的问题
好OK好的
今天时间那个控制的比较好
大概是一个半一个小时45分钟
那那个就是首先那个谢谢大家
那我们下一节课的话跟大家讲一些game in
那个game游戏引擎里面的工具链的
更有趣的一些内容
好的
那我们今天就到这
谢谢大家
谢谢同学们